WHAT GOOD GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY MINE'S A SOMEONE
NUMBER MARK BERMAN IT'S MY
HONOR TO REPRESENT THE TWENTY
FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY WHICH
INCLUDES NORTHERN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN SOUTHERN SAN MATTEO
COUNTY AND WE'RE CURRENTLY IN
LOS ALTOS WHICH IS KIND OF THE
HEART OF MY DISTRICT A LOT OF
FOLKS THINK OF SILICON VALLEY
AS AS- KIND OF A LOT OF
TECHNOLOGY. THIS AREA IS
INCREDIBLY DIVERSE IT REFLECTS
THE ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FROM AG
LAND ON THE COAST HALF MOON BAY
DOWN THE PESCADERO. BUT ALSO
THE HEART OF SILICON VALLEY
HERE IN LOS ALTOS AND A LOT OF
THE COMMUNITIES AROUND HERE.
IT'S ALSO A DISTRICT WITH A
INCREDIBLY LARGE AND THRIVING
API COMMUNITY MY DISTRICTS
ABOUT ONE THIRD A. P. I. ABOUT.
15% LATINO EXACTLY A MAJORITY
MINORITY DISTRICT WHICH A LOT
OF FOLKS DON'T REALIZE. SO I
REALLY WANT TO THINK DOCTOR
PAYNE FOR ORGANIZING THIS VERY
TIMELY DISCUSSION. THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING SO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE LEGISLATURE THE TWENTY
FOURTH IS ONLY DISTRICT ALSO
WANTED THINK THE SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION. WHICH IS
A HUGE ASSET TO NOT JUST
SILICON VALLEY BUT CALIFORNIA
AND ACTUALLY DOES WORK ALL
ACROSS THE GLOBE. AND WITH THAT
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
MY FRIEND AND MY PARTNER ON ALL
MATTERS RELATED TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY SIX THIS DOCTOR RICHARD
PAN. I THANK THANKS VERY MUCH
JEFF BERMAN AND- AND I WANNA
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WOKE ME
UP. TO YOUR DISTRICT AND REALLY
THRILLED TO BE BACK HERE. AGAIN
SO THIS IS A AN OFFICIAL
HEARING OF THE SO IT SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER AFFAIRS.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
BREAKING THE API GLASS CEILING
AND I ALSO WANT TO WELCOME MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUSES WELL HERE.
SO FIRST I GUESS I WILL
FORMALLY. OPEN THE HEARING.
OKAY WE ARE NOW IN HEARING
ABOUT OKAY SO MY INSTRUCTOR
RICHARD PAN I AM THE CHAIR OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE AND I AM.
REPRESENT THE SACRAMENTO REGION
IN THE STATES AT AND I'M ALSO
PRACTICING PEDIATRICIAN. AND I
CAN WHAT I THINK THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS FOR CO
HOSTING THIS HEARING. WITH US
AND I APPRECIATE. BOTH SO
MEMBERS COBRA AND- CHILD BEING
HERE I ALSO WANT TO I THINK UP
TO. THIS IS BUT G. AND DENISE
PACK THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
DURING THIS VENUE FOR THE
HEARING AS WELL AND I WAS WHAT
I THINK THE TOKEN VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION. AS WELL.
FOR HAVING US HERE. AND YEAH
WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
API EXPERIENCE IN THE WORKPLACE
AND CERTAINLY THERE SUFFICIENT
DATA TO SHOW THAT ASIANS ARE
NOT ADVANCING TO MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS AND I THINK PROBABLY
ARE PACIFIC ISLANDER FRIENDS AS
WELL HAVE FACED SIMILAR
CHALLENGES WELL AND CERTAINLY
IN MANY DIFFERENT PROFESSIONS
AND IN FACT IN THIS HEARING
WE'RE GOING TO PARTICULARLY TO.
ADDRESS THREE. OR AREAS THE
LEGAL PROFESSION ENTERTAIN INTO
JOURNALISM AND SINCE WE'RE HERE
IN THE CENTER OF TACK TACK BUT
I'M A PHYSICIAN AND ACTUALLY
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE NOT HAVING A
PANEL ON PHYSICIANS I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT. INCLUDING THE
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONS AND
PARTICULARLY MEDICINE. SO AS A
PHYSICIAN OFTEN TIMES IT'LL BE
POINTED OUT THAT ASIANS ARE
QUOTE OVER REPRESENTED AMONG
MEDICAL STUDENTS. THEY ARE OVER
REPRESENTED AMONG ACTUALLY
MEDICAL SCHOOL FACULTY. BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE DATA THE SHARES
IN MEDICAL SCHOOLS CREDIT
MEDICAL SCHOOLS UNITED STATES
ACTUALLY WE ARE TREMENDOUSLY
UNDER REPRESENTED IN FACT THE
PERCENTAGE OF API DEPARTMENT
CHAIRS IS ACTUALLY SIMILAR TO
THE PERCENTAGE OF THOSE BLACK
AND LATINO. DEPARTMENT CHAIRS
NOT TO SAY THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED AS WELL IN THAT
LEVEL AND SO AND I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT OF THE MEDICAL OF ALL
THE CREDIT MEDICAL SCHOOLS IN
THE UNITED STATES WE HAVE ABOUT
I THINK A HUNDRED FIFTY OF
THEM. DESPITE OUR SUPPOSEDLY
OVER REPRESENTATION IN. IN
AMONG FACULTY THERE ARE NONE
ZERO. NONE NO API MEDICAL
SCHOOL DEANS IN THE UNITED
STATES. THINK ABOUT THAT IN A
IN A FIELD THAT OFTEN PEOPLE
SAY THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF.
ASIANS. THERE ARE NONE HAVE ARE
CURRENTLY SERVING AS THE DEAN
OF THE MEDICAL SCHOOL AND YET
STATES EVEN THOUGH THERE'S A
HUNDRED FIFTY MORE HUNDRED
FIFTY MEDICAL SCHOOLS IN THE
UNITED STATES. AND I THINK THAT
AGAIN SPEAKS TO SO I'M THAT'S
JUST MY OWN PROFESSION THEY
WANT TO SHARE SINCE WOULD I
HAVE A SEPARATE PANEL THAT SO I
THINK THAT AGAIN THAT SORT OF
TALKS ABOUT THE PERVASIVENESS
OF THIS ISSUE ACROSS. THE
MULTIPLE FOR REGION SO I'M VERY
INTERESTED IN HEARING FROM OUR
WITNESSES AND A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT FIELDS THAT WE ARE
HAVING HEARD TODAY IN
RECOGNIZING THAT WE ALSO EVEN
IN FIELDS THAT ARE NOT BEING
FIRST TODAY THIS IS. ALSO A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE SO WITH THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEFORE YOU
BEGIN GIVEN OPPORTUNITY TO
HOLLY THE FIRST LETTER CAUCUS
OF THAT WISH TO MAKE US SOME
OPENING REMARKS AS WELL. THE
SENATOR DOCTOR PAN. SHOWING ALL
OF ALL OF US UP. ANYWAY I
REALLY WANT TO THANK DOCTOR PAN.
BECAUSE WELL FIRST I WANT TO
THANK HIM FOR HIS COURAGE
DURING THIS LEGISLATIVE CYCLE.
I THINK A LOT OF YOU UNDERSTAND
AND HAVE SEEN WHAT HE'S BEEN
THROUGH. YET STOOD STRONG AND I
THINK IT'S A GREAT. A REMINDER
OF WHY WE DO WHAT WE DO. AND I
WANT TO THANK OUR OUR HOSTING
OR PERMIT FOR BEING SUCH A
GREAT PARTNER AS WELL. WHEN I
LOOK AROUND THE ROOM I SEE SO
MUCH. REALLY A FACTOR OF
CAPABLE A LEADER IS MADE BY
COMMITTEE ACROSS. SO MANY.
DIFFERENT SECTORS HEY AND SO
YOU KNOW. THAT BUT WELL GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY. WE CAN EXCEL.
AND IT'S ABOUT BEING GIVEN THAT
OPPORTUNITY AND IF NOT. WHY NOT
WHY ARE WE NOT GETTING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AND SO I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY. OF
FOR US TO DISCUSS THIS ACROSS
AGAIN OF. REST REALLY IMPORTANT
SECTORS. AND. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM OTHER WITNESSES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I MY NAME'S A CHOW I REPRESENT
FORTY NINE TO SOME A DISTRICT
IT IS TRULY THE LIKE FOR ME TO
BE. ANTHONY SAWED OFF BY
THINKING I'LL HOLLY SO SOMEONE
NUMBER APARTMENT FOR HOSTING US
HERE TODAY ALSO WANT TO THANK
GOD TALKED PAN. AND HIS ENTIRE
TEAM FOR IN TODAY'S. AND THIS
IS A VERY BORN HEARING. YEAH IN
FACT TELEVISION WITH YOU THAT
IS MY BIRTHDAY YET. YET I MAY I
CHOSE TO BE HERE SO. SO DODD.
BASICALLY IT DEMONSTRATES HOW
IMPORTANT THIS THING IS TO ME.
ALL RIGHT. I SO THE FORTY NINE
A SUMMIT DISTRICT ACTUALLY IS
THE FIRST APR MAJORITY THE
DISTRICT IN THE UNITED STATES
WE HAVE ABOUT 53% ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS. SO I THINK SOME
AMERICANS AND SHE HAS THE
SECOND MOST POPULOUS API A
POPULATION I THINK HE HAS A
FIFTY ONE AND I JUST WANT TO
BRIEFLY I THANK ALL OF THE
PRESENTERS FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND ALL IN ALL THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR BEING HERE IN I THANK ALL
OF YOU FOR YOUR COUNTRY AS TO
THE COMMUNITY ALSO. AND OUT YOU
KNOW MY THING IS WE HAVE MADE
TREMENDOUS CONTRIBUTION AS AS A
COMMUNITY BUT YET THERE'S ROOM
FOR SO MUCH MORE TO DO SO I
LOOK FOR TO HEAR TESTIMONIES
AND YEAH YOUR THOUGHTS AND YOU
KNOW TO HOW HOW TO DO A YOU
KNOW GOING GOING FORWARD SO.
WITHOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME. OKAY THANK YOU AND
MAY BEFORE WE ALSO BEFORE WE- I
WANT A RECOGNIZE THAT GINA
DOLMA FROM SIN SO CAN VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION. DID YOU
WANNA MAKE A FEW REMARKS ABOUT
THE FOUNDATION. OKAY AT THEY
HAVE YOU COME UP TO THE. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR HOSTING HAVING US
HERE THANK YOU. BLACK WELL I
GUESS TECHNICALLY SHOULD USED
AS IS BECAUSE WE ARE HEARING. I
THINK IT'S WRONG YEAH. THERE WE
GO THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER OF
ADVANTAGE WELCOME EVERYONE WHAT
AN ABSOLUTE PRIVILEGE ADD TO
HAVE YOU ALL HERE WE WANT
ESPECIALLY AT THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR
PRESIDENT AND CEO NICOLE TAYLOR
WHO COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY IF
SHE'S AT STANFORD PRESENTING ON
FLAT. OUR MISSION SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IS
AT TO SOLVE THE REGION'S MOST
CHALLENGING PROBLEMS IN THE WAY
WE DO THAT. IS WITH WITH
PARTNERING WITH CHANGE MAKERS
LIKE LIKE ALL OF YOU. LIKE OUR
MEMBERS IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AS WELL AS ADD COMMUNITY FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
SO WHAT WE HOPE FOR TODAY IS
THAT THE SPACE OUT PROVIDES YOU
A AT AN ADDITIONAL CONTEXT. I
HAD TO KEEP FIGHTING THE GOOD
FIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
BOARD ROOMS AT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR THE FOUNDATION HEADS.
REALLY REFLECT WHAT'S SO
BEAUTIFUL ABOUT OUR STATE NOW
WITH THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AND WELCOME TO
OUR UNIVERSE. THANK YOU THANKS
VERY MUCH THE STOMACH FOR BUT
GREETING AND THE WELCOME THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. SO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH
OUR FIRST PANELIST. SENDING THE
LEGAL PROFESSION WE HAVE THE
HONORABLE RUPA GOSWAMI A LOS
ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
HERE ONE. IS HERE SHE'S THE
FIRST SOUTH ASIAN WOMAN ON THE
BENCH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN PRIOR TO JOINING
THE BENCH TO SERVED AS A
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR IN UNITED
STATES ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
DURING THAT TIME SHE PROSECUTED
CYBER CRIME FRAUD ENVIRONMENTAL
CRIMES CHILD SEX TOURISM AND
CRIMES INVOLVING THE DANGER
SPECIES AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
ALSO THE YOUR HONOR THAT YOU
WERE ALSO INVOLVED WORKED WITH
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE GOOD
INCLUDE ONE STUDY OF LOOKING AT
BASICALLY THE REDUCTION OF API.
ATTORNEYS TO TED SHIPS AND. AND
THAT PROGRESS SO WELCOME AND WE
LOOK FOR TO YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
THANK YOU. I THINK I'M I'M ON
RIGHT YES OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN FOR HAVING ME HERE
I WANT TO START BY TELLING YOU
SORT OF WHY I'M SO THRILLED. TO
BE ADDRESSING THIS ROOM A
FABULOUS PEOPLE FIRST OF ALL
LIKE MANY OF YOU IN THIS ROOM
I'M GREAT TO THE UNITED STATES
MY PARENTS EMIGRATED FROM INDIA
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES. AND
WENT STARTED GRADE SCHOOL HERE
I DIDN'T SPEAK ENGLISH. AT AND
GROWING UP I DIDN'T KNOW A
SINGLE LAWYER SO TO BE SITTING
HERE AT SAVE FEDERAL PROCESS
CUTER AND NOW A STATE COURT
JUDGE. IT'S AN INCREDIBLE
THRILL. A G. M. TO BE RIGHT AND
I HAVE THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
FOR HIGHLIGHTING A GREAT. SOME
OF BLACKS FOR EIGHT AMERICANS
SO THE SHIN. FOR ME TODAY IS
HOW ARE WE GOING IN. I WANT TO
START BY SAYING WE HAVE A LOT
TO CELEBRATE ALL RIGHT ARE
CHIEF JUSTICE ON THE SUPREME
COURT. IS DONE YOU CAN DO THE
SECOND WAY. WE JUST RECENTLY
GOT A NEW CHAIR FOR THE
COMMISSION ON JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE WHICH IS THE WATCH
STRONG GROUP THAT WATCHES THE
PERFORMANCE OF ALL THE STATE
COURT JUDGES AND THAT CHAIR IS
NANCY. NISHIMURA SO WE
CERTAINLY HAVE POINTS OF LIGHT
TO CELEBRATE. IF USE TAKE A
STEP BACK AND LOOK AT ASIAN
AMERICANS IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
WE MAKE UP ONLY 2% OF ALL STATE
COURT JUDGES AND STATE COURT
JUDGES ARE. THE IMPORTANT WHICH
BUT 90% OF THE LEGAL WORK IN
AMERICA. WE DO A LOT OF HEAVY
LIFTING ONLY 2% OF ALL STATE
COURT JUDGES. WE'RE ONLY 3% OF
ALL FEDERAL JUDGES BUT IT ALICE
YEAH ACTUALLY DOING BETTER AND
PART OF. AND WE'RE DOING BETTER
IS BECAUSE OF PEOPLE LIKE THIS.
OKAY IN THE LAST SEVEN YEARS
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN HAS
APPOINTED A SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO
SEVENTY ASIAN AMERICAN JUDGES
AND THE LAST SEVEN YEARS IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE OF EFFORTS
LIKE THIS GETTING THE WORD OUT
GETTING PEOPLE TO APPLY GETTING
US MOVING FORWARD NO ASIAN
AMERICANS OR 16% THE POPULATION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE NOW 7% OF THE STATE
COURT JUDICIARY A HUGE STEP
FORWARD AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
I THINK WE'RE GONNA SEE MORE OF
THIS WITH THE NEW GOVERNOR WITH
GOVERNOR. SOME A GOOD TRACK.
WERE BROWN. EXCELLENT
APPOINTMENTS LIKE ME. I HAVE TO
SAY IT'S BEEN AN EXCITING TIME
FOR US BUT AS SENATOR PAN SAID
THERE IS A STUDY THAT WAS PUT
TOGETHER BY JUSTUS GOODWIN LIU
WITH HELP FROM THE PABA AND THE
YALE LAW SCHOOL AND THAT STUDY
GIVES US A NUMBER OF A NUMBER
OF NUMBERS ACTUALLY ABOUT THE
STATE OF ASIAN AMERICANS AND
THE LAW AND IT REALLY COMES TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT WE STILL
HAVE A LONG LONG WAY TO GO. SO
IN THE LAST THIRTY YEARS THE
NUMBER OF ASIAN AMERICANS GOING
TO LAW SCHOOL INSTEAD OF
MEDICAL SCHOOL HAS INCREASED IT
HAS ACTUALLY QUADRUPLED SO WE
HAVE SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF
ASIAN AMERICANS BEING INTO THE
FASHION. BUT THAT SOME IS NOT.
EITHER IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR OR
IN THE PUBLIC SERVICE ARENA. SO
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS LARGE LAW FIRMS
BIG TOP TEN LAW FIRMS THERE
CERTAINLY HIRING A MAID AT
ASIAN AMERICAN LAWYERS FACT. IF
YOU LOOK AT A LAW FIRM AND YOU
COUNT UP ALL THE ASIAN AND ALL
THE ALL THE MINORITY ASSOCIATES
AND PARTNERS. ASIAN AMERICANS
ACTUALLY REPRESENT THE LARGEST
MINORITY GROUP IN PRIVATE LAW
FIRMS. BUT THEY'RE ALSO THE
ASSOCIATES THAT HAVE THE
HIGHEST ATTRITION RATES AND THE
LOWEST RATIO OF PARTNERS TO
ASSOCIATES. SO TRANSLATION
THEY'RE LEAVING IN DROVES AND
THEY'RE NOT MOVING UP. AND WE
SEE THAT SAME TREND ECHOED IN
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC SERVICE SO
ONE OF THE M. IN. THAT CAME OUT
OF THIS STUDY WAS THAT MOST
ASIAN AMERICANS DON'T GO INTO
THE LEGAL PROFESSION THINKING
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GO INTO
GOVERNMENT OR THINKING IF
THEY'RE GOING TO GO INTO PUBLIC
SERVICE. AND IT'S ONE OF THOSE
CHICKEN AND EGG ISSUES RIGHT
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T SEE PEOPLE
IN THOSE POSITIONS YOU CAN'T
IMAGINE YOURSELF BEING THERE
BECAUSE YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO
DREAM IT FIRST RIGHT. SO LET'S
TAKE A LOOK AT NATIONAL NUMBERS
SO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
IMPORTANT PEOPLE YOUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR YOUR COUNTY IS
NUMBER ONE LONG FORCE LAWYER
YOUR ACCOUNT. IT IS THINGS
LIKE. WE'RE GOING TO GO AFTER.
OR GOING TO GO AFTER DRUGS AND
GANGS RIGHT THEY MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT WHO IS GOING TO BE HIRED
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO PUT OUR
RESOURCES WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
EMPHASIZE. SO THIS STUDY FOUND
THAT OUT OF THE TWO THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN.
ELECTED DISTRICT ATTORNEYS IN
THE NATION. HOW MANY WERE ASIAN
AMERICAN. FOUR FOUR OKAY ONLY
FOR AND THIS HAPPENS AGAIN ON
THE FEDERAL SIDE SO WE HAVE
FOUR FEDERAL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
NINETY FOUR IN THE NATION OKAY
SO IN TWENTY SIXTEEN OUT OF
NINETY FOUR POTENTIAL TOP
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS IN THE
COUNTRY A GRAND TOTAL OF THREE
WERE ASIAN AMERICAN. ONE FOR
ONE. ONE FOR HAWAII AND- THERE
ARE A- JOSH SOMEBODY YOU MIGHT
KNOW FROM THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT
OF NEW YORK THAT WAS IT FOR THE
ENTIRE NATION OKAY. THEN WE SEE
THIS AGAIN IN ACADEMIA AS
SENATOR PAN SAID YOU KNOW
APPARENTLY WERE OVER
REPRESENTED. BUT NOT REALLY I
ROSE LAW SCHOOL DEANS THERE ARE
TWO HUNDRED AND TWO IN THE
COUNTRY AND IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
ONLY THREE WERE ASIAN AMERICAN
SO CERTAINLY THERE'S WORK TO BE
DONE HERE AND I WILL PULL IT
BACK TO CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE-
LARGEST ASIAN AMERICAN PIE
RELATION OF ANY STATE. WE ARE
16% OF THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE
CALIFORNIA. IN. THE COUNTY
BATES NUMBER. 38% RATE IN MY
OWN COUNTY WE'RE 14% THE CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO 36% WE'RE BIG
NUMBERS RIGHT AND DOES ANYBODY
KNOW HOW MANY COUNTIES WE HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA. FIFTY EIGHT
CIVICS OKAY WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT TOO ALL RIGHT PEOPLE WE
HAVE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE HAVE FIFTY
EIGHT ELECTED DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OKAY IN CALIFORNIA
THE STATE WITH THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF ASIAN AMERICANS HOW
MANY DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ARE
ASIAN AMERICAN IN CALIFORNIA.
OKAY. ONE AGAIN THIS IS A
CHICKEN AND EGG SITUATION RIGHT
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T EVER SEE
PEOPLE IN THESE POSITIONS MAYBE
YOU CAN IMAGINE YOURSELF
SITTING IN THAT CHAIR RIGHT.
BEFORE I KNOW YOUR BRAIN WITH
FACTS AND FIGURES AND
PERCENTAGES LET ME TAKE A STEP
BACK AND ASK THE QUESTION WHY
WHY DOES IT MATTER OKAY WHY
DOES IT MATTER. THAT WE HAVE
DIVERSITY ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES REPRESENTED IN THE
LEGAL PROFESSION. WELL FIRST OF
ALL I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE
LAW AFFECTS ABSOLUTELY EVERY
ASPECT OF YOUR LIFE WE ARE A
NATION OF LAWS. WHETHER YOU'RE
GETTING A DIVORCE OR FILING
BANKRUPTCY HAVE A CONTRACT
DISPUTE YOU HAVE A TENANT YOU
WANNA VICT WE'RE GOD FOR BID
YOUR DAUGHTERS JUST BEEN PICKED
UP ON RECKLESS DRIVING AND
CHARGED. WITH A MISDEMEANOR
GUESS WHERE YOU'RE GOING. OR
YOU'RE WALKING INTO A
COURTHOUSE. WHAT DO YOU WANT IN
THAT COURTHOUSE YOU WANT A FAIR
SHAKE. YOU WANT TO BE HEARD
RIGHT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR SO LET'S SAY YOU
WALK INTO A COURTHOUSE IN YOU
SEE THAT GREAT BIG DIRECTORY
WITH ALL THE NAMES OF THE
JUDGES THAT SIT IN THAT
COURTHOUSE. AND YOU SEE AMES
LIKE. AS AND WEST SHOE AND
DOROTHY CAM. MAYBE YOU WALK
AWAY AND YOU LOOK AND YOU THINK
TO YOURSELF OKAY I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE ETHNICITY OF MY JUDGES
GONNA BE BUT I SEE THAT THESE
POOL OF DECISION MAKERS. ARE
DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE AND MAYBE
YOU FEEL OKAY I'M GOING TO BE
HEARD. AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
WHAT STUDIES LIKE THE GAVEL GAP
WHICH IS ANOTHER TERRIFIC STUDY
I ONLY GET FIFTEEN MINUTES WILL
TELL US IT TELLS US THAT THE
GAVEL MATTERS FOR HOW
CONFIDENT. ARE ABOUT SHARE. IF
YOU PULL IN STUDY AFTER STUDY
MOST OF WHAT AMERICA THEY COME
TO THE CONCLUSION. ABOUT 70% OF
FOLKS CAUCASIAN FOLKS WILL SAY
WE HAVE CONFIDENCE IN OUR
JUDICIARY WITH THAT NUMBER
DROPS TO ONLY 50% WHEN AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE PULLED. SO THIS
GAVEL GAP IS IMPORTANT AND
INCLUSION IS IMPORTANT SOMEBODY
TELL YOU A LITTLE STORY ABOUT
HOW THIS PLAYS OUT IN ONE
PARTICULAR CASE SO A COUPLE
YEARS BACK THERE WAS A CASE AND
DEPENDENCY COURT. DEPENDENCY
COURT IS WHERE YOU GO WHEN YOUR
CHILDREN ARE GOING TO BE TAKEN
AWAY. BECAUSE OF EITHER
EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL ABUSE. TRIAL
COURT JUDGE HEARD MILLIONS OF
THE FACT THAT THE MOTHER IN
THIS CASE WOULD DISCIPLINE HER
CHILDREN A WITH THE CHAPEL OKAY
IT'S A- SANDEL SO SHE WOULD
TAKE OFF FOR FLIP FLOP AND SHE
WOULD. WACKER KID ON THE BETH
OR TAPPER KID ON THE **** NOW
FOR MANY OF US IN THIS ROOM
THAT'S NOT A COMPLETELY UNUSUAL
FORM OF CHILD DISCIPLINE YOU
MAY HAVE BEEN FAMILIAR WITH THE
CHAPEL IN YOUR YOUTH. BUT THIS
PARTICULAR TRIAL J. MADE RULING
THAT IT WAS PURSUING A
CATEGORICAL SIRIUS PHYSICAL
HARM. TO HIT A CHILD WITH A
CHAPEL. AND IT WAS A CONCLUSION
THAT THAT'S A IT'S A PER SE
RULE SO THIS CASE WENT UP TO
THE COURT OF APPEAL AND IT
ENDED UP BEING COMING BEFORE A
FRIEND OF MINE BRIAN HAAS THAT
NO BRIGHT HOUSE SAID IS THIS
TALL BLONDE GUY. STAT JUSTICE
BRAND HOUSE THAT. UCLA LAW
SCHOOL I WENT TO UCLA LAW
SCHOOL WHEN I WENT TO UCLA LAW
SCHOOL 49% OF MY INCOMING CLASS
WAS NON WHITE. AND 51% OF MY
CLASS WERE WOMEN. THAT'S THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT BRIAN GOT HIS
LEGAL EDUCATION IN. THEN HE
WENT TO WORK FOR THE US
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND WHEN HE
WAS THERE. IN THE HISTORY OF
THE US ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE HAD
AN ASIAN AMERICAN HEAD OF THE
OFFICE. YANKEES AND- BRIAN
WORKED WITH ALL OF US HE WORKED
WITH PETER HERNANDEZ ANYWAY
SHOE AND DOROTHY CAN'T M. AND
BE. THAT INFORMED HIS
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW TO BRING
CALIFORNIA RAISED. AND AS IT
TURNS OUT BRIAN REVERSE THE
TRIAL COURT JUDGE. SO I AM NOT
SAYING THAT YOU NEED TO HAVE
ANY PARTICULAR ETHNICITY ON THE
BENCH I'M NOT SAYING YOU NEED
TO HAVE ANY PART PARTICULAR
ETHNICITY AS YOUR LAWYER WHAT
I'M SAYING IS THAT WE NEED TO
BE INCLUSIVE BECAUSE WE ALL
BENEFIT FROM SHARING OUR-
EXPERIENCES FROM GOING TO LUNCH
WITH ONE ANOTHER FROM TALKING
ABOUT OUR CASES. AND THAT MOM
BUYS HOW WE C. CALIFORNIA AND
HOW WE DECISIONS HERE. SO AS I
WRAP UP GET TO ANSWER ONE MORE
QUESTION WHICH IS WHERE DO WE
GO FROM HERE ANTONY'S PACK
BEING A GENIUS WAS THE FIRST
QUESTION SHE SAID TO ME SHE
SAID WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE.
AND I SAID WHAT A GREAT
QUESTION SO FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO PUT THIS IN THE CONTEXT THAT
SENATOR PAN IS GOING TO
UNDERSTAND SO I LOOK AT
SOMETHING LIKE. THIS AS THAT
DIAGNOSE. RIGHT FOR YOU. WHAT
DISEASE SOMEBODY HAS OR WHAT.
TUMOR YOU GO GET AN MRI I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE HECK YOU DO WOULD
YOU DO SOMETHING IN THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION. AND THAT'S WHY
THESE KIND OF STUDIES ARE SO
IMPORTANT SO I WOULD LOVE TO
SEE A TASK FORCE. THAT DOES
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE TODAY AND
KEEPS MOVING FORWARD AND
GETTING US THE NUMBER. AND THE
NEW WANTS TO ANALYSIS THAT
HELPS US UNDERSTAND. HOW DO WE
MOVE FORWARD. I MEAN IT'S VERY
BOTTOM LINE IS. RIGHT WE MAKE A
CHANGE. IN THE BALLOT BOX VOTED
FOR CHANGE. WE ALSO HAVE
ANOTHER REALLY POWERFUL
MECHANISM FOR CHANGE THAT'S A
NICE TO EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM
WERE ALL CONSUMERS. YOU BYE.
LEGAL PRODUCTS. SOMEONE TELL
YOU ABOUT MY BROTHER.
COOMARASWAMY HE'S- A LITTLE
START UP ON HIS THIRD. START UP
THEY'RE NOT SO LITTLE ANYMORE.
WHEN HE SAW SEPT ARTE SAID. HE
HAD TO HAVE A LEGAL TEAM TO
MANAGE THE M. EIGHTEEN. AND HE
WENT TO ONE OF THE TOP LAW
FIRMS AND HE SAID I'M A DIVERSE
COMPANY I REPRESENT. A DIVERSE
CLIENTS. WE'RE WE'RE TWO ASIANS
AND A NICE SCOTTISH AMERICAN
GUY AND WE WANT A DIVERSE LEGAL
TEAM. AND THAT NUMBER ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE LAW FIRM GAVE
HIM A SENIOR PARTNER WHO'S
HISPANIC. A SENIOR PARTNER
WHO'S A WOMAN AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN ASSOCIATE. SO
BASICALLY HE DEMANDED DIVERSITY
SO. THAT'S THE OTHER FOR CHANGE
WE CAN IMPLEMENT I THINK SO
MUCH FOR ME AND I'LL BE AROUND
FOR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I SHOULD MENTION
THAT I HAVE A BROTHER WHO IS
ACTUALLY IN THE TOURNEY.
ACTUALLY HE WAS ASSOCIATED.
DECIDED THAT DE DID MOVE ON THE
PARTNER DECIDE TO PURSUE OTHER
PATHS SO I GET THE STORY TO
SHARE. SO QUESTIONS FROM WELL
FROM THE CAUCUS MEMBERS SUMMER
CAR. THANK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER PAN AND THANK YOU A
JUDGE TO SWAMI I AGREE WITH
YOUR ASSESSMENT I THINK THAT
THE GOVERNMENT EXCELLENT CHOICE.
AND YOU KNOW I AM HAVING. BEING
IN THE SAME PROFESSION AND HE
WAS ON THE BAR ASSOCIATION MY
COUNTY. TWO DECADES AGO TALK
ABOUT THE SAME ISSUES AND
WHETHER WAS LAW FIRM LOANS LAW
FIRMS FOR AS YOU INDICATED IN
PUBLIC SERVICE AND EVERY C.
THIS IN TEXAS ON SO MANY
DIFFERENT ARENAS WHERE AND THE
SENATOR JUST PURCHASED. WHERE
WE DON'T GET IT BACK. WE JUST
AND. JOHN SHOP BUT I SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO BE THAT WAY WHAT
WHETHER YOU'RE PREGNANT TRYING
TO ADVANCE WITHIN. A DA OR
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE COUNTY
COUNCIL WHAT HAVE YOU. TRYING
TO GET IT A JUDGE APPOINTMENT
OR TRYING TO ADVANCE YOUR LAW
FIRM WHERE YOUR CORPORATE
SETTING. AND SO YOU KNOW. WHAT
I GUESS IS KIND OF THE
REPETITION OF HAVING TO DEAL
WITH THIS ISSUE. TIME AND AGAIN
AND I AND I ACTUALLY LOVE THE
EXAMPLE YOU AND IT BETH.
BECAUSE THE FIRMS JUST LIKE
ANYONE ELSE THEY'RE GOING TO.
THEY'RE GONNA DICTATE THINGS BY
THEIR POCKETBOOK AND SO.
CLIENTS ARE DEMANDING SOMETHING
THEY'LL MOVE WHEN I GUESS SO
HOW DO WE- HOW DO WE REACH OUT
BEYOND THE SO CALLED API
COMMUNITY THAT'S REALLY PAYING
ATTENTION TO THIS TWO PEOPLE
THAT ARE POSITIONS YOUR BROTHER
OR A POSITION LIKE YOU KNOW WHO
LIVE IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
HOW DO WE GET BEYOND OUTSIDE OF
THOSE THAT ARE. HERE TODAY
BECAUSE THEY KNOW ABOUT THE
ISSUES OF LEARN MORE ABOUT IT
WHAT IS YOUR SUGGESTION FOR
THAT AND IT THE TIME HE'D BEEN
DOING THIS WORK WELL I ACTUALLY
DO THE BAR ASSOCIATIONS ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. HAD YOU
KNOW WE HAVE ETHNIC BARS YET
THE SOUTH ASIAN BAR WE HAVE A
POP UP WE HAVE. NO PABLO WHICH
HELP PUT THIS STUDY TOGETHER
THEY'RE ALL VERY IMPORTANT. BUT
I WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO SEE
YOU KNOW THE ABA. TO START
LOOKING AND HAVING SOME
COMMITTEES ON MENTORING AND
MENTORSHIP AND ONE UNDERLYING
ISSUES FOR ASIAN AMERICAN
LAWYER IS FOR MANY OF US WITH
THE FIRST LAWYERS IN OUR
FAMILIES. AND THAT'S TRUE FOR
HIS I THINK AMERICANS IT'S- YOU
KNOW TRUE ACROSS THE BOARD. SO
A LOT OF THIS IS LIKE JUST
BASIC MENTORING RIGHT YOU KNOW
TELLING PEOPLE HATE TAKE A YOU
KNOW. I CAME OUT A LAW SCHOOL
AND WENT TO A VERY LARGE LAW
FIRM AND MADE WITH MAKING AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY LIKE.
YOU KNOW MORE THAN I HAD EVER
IMAGINED I TOOK A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR PAY CUT. TO GO
CLERK FOR A JUDGE RIGHT MY
MOTHER OH MY GOSH SHE'S LIKE
YOU'RE THIS STUPID AS OF MY
THREE CHILDREN YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW HOW I AM. WITH YOU RIGHT.
BUT THIS IS YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
TO HAVE SOMEBODY TELL YOU. YOU
KNOW ZIG TODAY RIGHT AND WE
NEED MAINSTREAM BAR
ASSOCIATIONS. TO TAKE IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO MOVE THIS. YEAH.
WHEN I WENT THIS ONE FROM
PUBLIC DEFENDERS CANCEL A TWO
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND. AND THE
LIKE I WAS OUT OF THE BOX YOU
FROM ABOUT GOING TO LAW SCHOOL
TO BEGIN WITH SO. I THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FOR VALIDATING MY.
M. PRESHOW HE'S WELL LET'S SAY
A FIRST WHEN THE PEDIATRICS IS
LESS PAYING OF ALL THE MEDICAL
SPECIALTIES AND THEN I WENT TO
POLITICS. STILL THE SAME WAY.
AS A MEMBER. IT'S GOING TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO THANK THE JUDGE FOR
NUMBER ONE WHICH COMING HERE TO
CHERYL WITH AS HER EXPERIENCES
AND ALSO WANT TO THANK HER FOR
US SELECTING PUBLIC SERVICE.
FOR SO MANY YEARS AND DODD NOT
ONLY THAT BUT I THINK YOU'RE
HELPING TO KIND OF CHANGED THE
LANDSCAPE AND CHANGING THE
STEREO TYPE OF ASIAN AMERICAN
THAT BY BEING A JUDGE IN IN THE
COURT ROOM. AND UP YOU KNOW. I
WANT TO SHARE IT OUT YOU KNOW I
A COUPLE OF INCIDENT IN THE
PAST I PRACTICED LAW FOR ABOUT
EIGHTEEN YEARS BEFORE. BEING
ELECTED TO THIS ASSEMBLY. AND
WHAT THINGS THAT HAPPENED IN A
WHAT INTO A COURT ROOM IS AT. I
MISSED. THE OUT. THE CLERK IN
HIS EYES ARE I ARE YOU YOU'RE
HERE EARLY AND MISTER
INTERPRETER. YOU KNOW SO THAT'S
A VERY COMMON PHENOMENON THAT
THAT WOULD HAPPEN TO ME BUT YOU
KNOW I WE NEED CHANGED.
PERCEPTION THAT AND SKATE DODD
MOVEMENTS SO. ONE OF THANK YOU
FOR BEING THAT. DOING HELPING
GIVE. HIS. SO I GUESS I. ONE
MORE BRIEF QUESTION SO YOU TALK
ABOUT AND THIS IS SOMETHING OUT
OF JOEL CROSSCUT. FROM PANELS
BUT SO IF SOMEONE SAYS OKAY I'M
GOING TO GO AND BE A LAWYER FOR
WHATEVER REASON NOW I AND THERE
THE FIRST IN THE FAMILY AND
THEN. NOW WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT HOW DO YOU TAKE
AGAIN AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF A. P. R.
ATTORNEYS IN TERMS OF
PROPORTION BUT THEN NOW WE
WANTED TO GO PURSUE THAT'S A
JUDGESHIP. HOW DO WE GET PEOPLE
TO SEE THEMSELVES IN THAT ROLE
IN ADDITION TO CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW YOU SEND EXAMPLE BEING A
JUDGE AND SO FORTH TO DO TO
HELP GET. THAT VISION AND
PEOPLE MIGHT SEEM SELVES
PARTNER JUDGE IN THOSE
LEADERSHIP ROLES AND WHAT DO
YOU THINK IS THE MAIN BARRIER
TO GETTING PEOPLE THEY'RE NOT
JUST PEOPLE SEEING THEM THOSE
THEY'RE PLANNING FOR THAT SO.
WELL I THINK THE VISION IS ONE
OF THE BEARS I THINK IT THEY
THE PROBLEM WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS NOT BEING INTO LEGAL
PROFESSION PUBLIC SERVICE MINE.
IS PRETTY IT WOULD LEAD TO
MENTAL THE LEAD. IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION AND WE'RE MORE
POROUS THAN AREAS WE MOVED
BETWEEN PRIVATE PRACTICE AND
PUBLIC SERVICE QUITE A BIT. AND
SO DEAD YANG WHO WAS THE ONLY
ASIAN AMERICAN TO LEAD THE US
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN LOS
ANGELES. IS A PARTNER AT GIBSON
DUNN AND CRUTCHER AND IF I.
BASED ON WHAT SHE'S DRIVING SHE
SEEMS. VERY WELL BUT YOU KNOW
ASIAN AMERICAN FAMILIES DON'T
ALWAYS SEE THAT THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A BETH THERE'S A
WONDERFUL BENEFIT TO PRIVATE
PUBLIC SERVICE I WILL BE IN
PUBLIC SERVICE ALL MY LIFE
BECAUSE I LOVE THIS. BUT
THERE'S THERE CAN ALSO BE A
MONETARY BENEFIT TO THAT SO
ANOTHER AREA WERE ASIAN
AMERICANS ARE TERRIBLY
UNDERREPRESENTED ISN'T
CLERKSHIPS SO NATION WIDE ONLY
4% OF ALL STATE CLERKSHIPS ARE
FILLED WITH ASIAN AMERICAN. THE
SIX PER CENT OF FEDERAL
CLERKSHIPS LET ME PUT THIS IN
CONTEXT AGAIN. ASIAN AMERICANS
NOT ONLY GO TO LAW SCHOOL BUT-
WELL. OKAY THE TOP 10% OUT OF
THE TOP THIRTY LAW SCHOOL IN M.
RECCA ASIAN AMERICAN. YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS THEY'RE DOING
GREAT THEY'RE ON LAW REVIEW THE
ORDER OF THE COIF THERE AT THE
TOP OF THEIR GAME OKAY BUT
THEY'RE NOT GOING INTO THAT
NEXT INCREDIBLY. AGES. BOB OF
SHIPS. LOOK AT THE JUSTICES ON
THE SUPREME COURT NOTICE MOST
OF THEM CLERKED RIGHT MOST OF
THE FEDERAL JUDGE'S CLERK RIGHT
I TOOK THAT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR PAGE PAY CUT TO BE A
FEDERAL CLERK AND THEN TO BE AN
APPELLATE CLICK RIGHT AND MY
MOTHER CRIED AGAIN BECAUSE IT
WAS ANOTHER OF MAKING NO MONEY
RIGHT. BUT THAT END OF THERE'S
COULD IN AND THERE'S A PULL AND
THE PUSH RIGHT ASIAN AMERICANS
HAVE TO PUT THEMSELVES OUT
THERE BUT WE ALSO NEED THE
ASIAN AMERICAN JUDGES AND
ACTUALLY ALL JUDGES I MEAN YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE ASIAN AMERICAN
TO HIRE AN ASIAN AMERICAN
RIGHT. BUT THE NUMBERS IT'S
NOT. WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOUR HONOR
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
LEGISLATION THANK YOU FOR THE
STATE. ACTUALLY WE GO NEXT
PANEL THAT. THANK YOU. OKAY OUR
NEXT PANEL IS. GUARDING THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY AND
WE'RE REALLY THRILLED TO HAVE
MICHELLE SECARA AND ADELE LIVE.
TO PRESENTS OF YOU I COME UP
HERE. MICHELLE CIGAR AS THE
SAVE DIRECTOR OF CAPE THE
COALITION OF ASIAN PACIFIC.
THERE'S AN ENTERTAINMENT AND
SHE'S ALSO AN ENTERTAINMENT
ATTORNEY A FILM PRODUCER AN
ADJUNCT PROFESSOR FOR A CLEAR
MYCOLOGIST INTERCOLLEGIATE
DEPARTMENT OF ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDIES. IS ALSO THE LEADERSHIP
ON THE LEADERSHIP TEAM OF
TIME'S UP ENTERTAINMENT API
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC AMERICAN FRIENDS OF THE
THEATER AND A MEMBER OF THE PBS
SOUTHERN. CALIFORNIA ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
COUNCIL. AND WE SO ARE DROP TO
HAVE. THIS IS A DELL LIMB TV
AND MOVIE WRITER PRODUCER WHO
CO WROTE THE SCREENPLAY FOR THE
POPULAR MOVIE CRAZY RICH
ASIANS. AND SHE ACTUALLY WAS
REPRESENT THE LAST AND OUR
HONOR IN HONORING THE- THE CAST
OF KEYS YOU CRAZY RICH ASIANS
OF A THRILL TO HAVE HER WITH US
AND SACRAMENTO'S WE HONOR THEM.
BUT SHE ALSO HAS RECENTLY
HEADLINES. WHEN HE TURNED DOWN
WARNER'S OFFER TO CO WRITE THE
SEQUEL THE CRAZY RICH ASIANS
BECAUSE I'VE A- PAY DISPARITIES
ALMOST AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT PAY
DISPARITY AND APPRECIATE HER
COURAGE AND STANDING UP TO THAT
AND HOPEFULLY WE DON'T NEED TO
HAVE ANYONE ELSE HAVE TO DO
THAT AGAIN. SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS WELL I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COURAGE TO STAND UP TO THE
AN EQUITY AND THE BRING LIGHT
TO THAT WOMEN AND MINORITIES
CONTINUE TO FACE IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT ST. THEY'LL BE
SPEAKING ON ASIANS AND SCREEN
MITCHELL STREET INSET SHOWS
HOLLYWOOD'S. I THINK WE'LL GO
AHEAD BEGIN THE. THE CIGAR AND
IN THE FALL OF THE THANK YOU
AND WELCOME. YEAH HELLO GREEN
LIGHT WILL COME ON IT'S ON. GOT
IT. THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY
I'M GONNA BE SPEAKING ABOUT
ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS IN MEDIA ADVANCING
TOWARD THE BREAKING POINT. A
BREAKING POINT IS DEFINED AS
THE MOMENT OF GREATEST STRAIN
WHERE SOMEONE OR SOME THING
GIVES WAY. HOW DO WE SHATTER
THE GLASS CEILING. ONE CRACK AT
A TIME UNTIL WE HIT. BREAKING
POINT I KEEP WE DREAM OF A
WORLD WHERE WHAT WE WATCHING OR
SCREENS REFLECTS THE WORLD IN
WHICH WE LIVE STRATEGICALLY WE
HAVE TARGETED TO CRITICAL
ACCESS POINTS IN HOLLYWOOD ONE
WRITERS BECAUSE DIVERSITY
STARTS ON THE PAGE AND TWO
EXECUTIVES BECAUSE INCLUDE
STARTS. WITH THE GATEKEEPERS.
WITH THESE TWO COURTS FROM THE
BOTTOM UP THE WRITERS AND THE
TOP DOWN WITH THE EXECUTIVES WE
ARE BUILDING A NEW ECOSYSTEM
AND FEEDBACK LOOP WHICH WILL
CREATE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ACTORS DIRECTORS AND PRODUCERS.
AND HE'S COUNTERVAILING FORCES
ARE ADDING MORE CRACKS TO THE
GLASS CEILING FROM THE WRITER'S
ROOM TO THE BOARDROOM.
ULTIMATELY AFFECTS WHAT WE
WATCH OUR LIVING. AND THE TIDE
IS TURNING UCLA'S TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN HOLLYWOOD DIVERSITY
REPORT NOTES THAT THE MINORITY
SHARE OF THE US POPULATION IS
INCREASING BY ABOUT A HALF
PERCENT EACH YEAR. FURTHERMORE
THE REPORT NOTES THAT AMERICA'S
INCREASINGLY DIVERSE AUDIENCE.
FOR DIVERSE FILM AND TELEVISION
CONTENT. BUT WHERE DOES THIS
CONTENT START. STARTS IN THE
MINDS OF THESE WRITERS WHO THEN
COMMITTED TO THE PAGE. SINCE
THE LATE NINETIES CAPE THE
COALITION OF ASIAN PACIFICS AN
ENTERTAINMENT HAS RECOGNIZED
THE IMPORTANCE OF WRITERS WE
STARTED WITH THE CAPE NEW
WRITERS AWARD WHICH WAS THEN
ELEVATED TO A FULL FLEDGED
FELLOWSHIP EIGHT YEARS AGO WHEN
WE REALIZED THAT TALENT WAS NOT
ENOUGH. WRITERS ALSO NEEDED TO
LEARN THE BUSINESS OF HOLLYWOOD.
I CAN DO THIS. IS IT ON IS IT.
IT'S NOT ON. HOT AT THE KIDNEY
WRITER'S FELLOWSHIP IS THE ONLY
ONE JOINTLY CREATED BY A
TELEVISION SHOW RUNNER AND A
TELEVISION NETWORK EXECUTIVE
AND IT HAS ONE OF THE BEST IF
NOT THE BEST TRACK RECORDS IN
GETTING WRITERS HIRED IN
HOLLYWOOD. ALUMNI YOUR WRITER'S
FELLOWSHIP HAVE BEEN STOPPED IN
EVERY MAJOR NETWORK STREAMING
PLATFORM WE HAVE NOW TWICE HAD
THE HONOR OF HAVING TO KEEP
ALUMNI IN THE SAME WRITER'S
ROOM WE UNDERSTAND THAT
SOMETIMES IT'S RARE TO HAVE
EVEN TO ASIAN AMERICAN WRITERS
IN ANY ROOM. SO TO HAVE TWO
FROM OUR FELLOWSHIP IS AN OFFER
THAT WE'RE VERY PROUD OF. ADULT
ONE OF OUR FAVORITE MENTOR
SHE'S BEEN INVOLVED FOR MANY
MANY YEARS AND RUNS OUR MOCK
WRITER'S ROOM. THIS TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN SO. HELLO THE
KID GRADUATES WERE STOPPED ON
STAR TREK DISCOVERY CHILLING
ADVENTURES OF SABRINA FRESH OFF
THE BOAT LORD OF THE RINGS LA'S
FINEST I'M DONE DIABLO GREY'S
ANATOMY LIGHT AS A FEATHER
ATYPICAL THE GOOD DOCTOR NANCY
DREW PACHINKO THE CURSE OF
MOLLY MCGEE CABINET ASK THE
WORLD AND AN UNANNOUNCED MARBLE
SHOW. ALSO THIS YEAR ONE OF OUR
FEATURE WRITERS WROTE NETFLIX
IS THE HALF OF IT AND ANOTHER
GRADUATE SIGNED AN OVERALL DEAL
WITH HBO AND THAT'S JUST
THROUGH TO DATE THERE ARE FEW
MORE ANNOUNCEMENTS THAT ARE
COMING DOWN WHEN THE EMBARGOES
LAST. MOREOVER DO I. REPUTATION
WE HAVE NOW BECOME THE GO TO
SOURCE FOR ASIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER WRITERS WE'VE
GOTTEN NUMEROUS WRITERS NOT
JUST OUR GRADUATES STAFF AND
SHOWS AND FEATURE FILM WRITING
GIGS. WE HAVE THE LARGEST AND
MOST IN DEPTH DATABASE OF ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
WRITERS IN HOLLYWOOD. NOW
SUPPORTING WRITERS IS
IMPORTANT. BUT WE ALSO NEED THE
CORPS LETTER FORCE EXECUTIVES
WHO WILL GREEN LIGHT AND
CHAMPION OUR PROJECTS. ASIAN
AMERICAN PROFESSIONALS OFTEN
AREN'T PROMOTED BECAUSE THEY
ARE PERCEIVED AS LACKING
ASSERTIVENESS AND LEADERSHIP
QUALITIES WHICH ARE STEREO
TYPES THAT ARE EXACERBATED BY
THE MEDIA. A RECENT A SON
FOUNDATION STUDY WHICH I'M SURE
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT LATER THIS
AFTERNOON. FOUND THAT ASIANS
ARE THE MOST LIKELY TO BE HIRED.
BUT THE LEAST LIKELY TO BE
PROMOTED. TOWARD THAT END. IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE
LAUNCHED THE CAPE LEADERS
FELLOWSHIP THIS FOCUSES ON
JUNIOR EXECUTIVES JUST BELOW
THE VICE PRESIDENT RANK AND
CREATIVE DECISION MAKING
DEPARTMENTS THAT IS DEVELOPMENT
CURRENT I'M PRODUCTION. IN
ADDITION TO PROVIDING
LEADERSHIP NETWORKING AND
COMMUNICATION SKILLS THIS
FELLOWSHIP STRENGTHENS
IMPORTANT NETWORKS OPEN DOORS
AND PROVIDES ACCESS TO INDUSTRY
LEADERS THAT ARE OFTEN OUT OF
REACH FOR LOWER LEVEL
EXECUTIVES. THIS FELLOWSHIP IS
THE ONLY JUNIOR EXECUTIVE
FELLOWSHIP IN HOLLYWOOD AND WE
BECOME THE GO TO SOURCE FOR
ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
EXECUTIVES IN A SHORT PERIOD OF
OUR FELLOWSHIPS EXISTENCE WE
HAVE PLACED SEVERAL EXECUTIVES
WITH GREAT OPPORTUNITIES. NO
MEDIA IS THE QUICKEST AND MOST
PERVASIVE WAY TO SHAPE
PERCEPTION PERCEPTION AN INTERN
REALITY. BECAUSE IMAGES MATTER.
THE IMAGES WE SEE AFFECT OUR
PERCEPTIONS OF OTHERS AS WELL
AS OF OURSELVES. BUT MEDIA ALSO
HAS THE POWER TO CREATE CHANGE
IN THE TIME THAT IT TAKES TO
MAKE A MOVIE TO CREATE A
TELEVISION SHOW WE CAN CHANGE
WHAT THAT FUTURE LOOKS LIKE.
WHAT ELSE CAN WE DO TO TACKLE
THIS ISSUE. ON THE TELEVISION
SIDE WE NEED MORE ASIAN
AMERICAN SHOW RUNNERS THE SHOW
RUNNER IS THE CAPTAIN OF THE
SHIP THE PERSON WITH THE
OVERALL CREATIVE AUTHORITY AND
MANAGEMENT RESPONSIBILITY OF A
TV SHOW. THIS IS A TV WRITERS
ROOM HIERARCHY. AT THE TOP WE
HAVE THE SHOW RUNNER. ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO STAFF WRITER. TO BE
A SHOW RUNNER EXECUTIVE
PRODUCER COEXECUTIVE PRODUCER
CONSULTING PRODUCER SUPERVISING
PRODUCER PRODUCER COPRODUCER
EXECUTIVE STORY EDITOR STORY
EDITOR AND STAFF WRITER SO
QUITE A HIERARCHY. NOW A DIRTY
A STUDY OF THE 200-017-2000
EIGHTEEN TV STAFFING SEASON
FOUND THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
LARGELY CONCENTRATED AT THE
LOWER LEVELS. SPECIFICALLY IT
NOTED THAT SYSTEM SYSTEMIC
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST WRITERS
FROM HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS REMAINS
PERVASIVE IN THE HIRING OF
TELEVISION WRITERS AND THAT THE
DISCRIMINATION IS WORSE AT THE
UPPER LEVELS. THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
SCRIPTED SHOWS. FIVE HUNDRED ON
VARIOUS PLATFORMS TODAY. BY OUR
COUNT THERE ARE ONLY ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE ASIAN AMERICAN SHOW
RUNNERS. THERE'S NO REASON WHY
WE CANNOT HAVE MORE SHOW
RUNNERS CALLING THE SHOTS. I
OFTEN RECEIVE CALLS OR EMAILS
FROM EXECUTIVES AND PRODUCERS
WHO SAY. WE NEED A SHOW RUNNER
WE PICKED UP A SHOW WE'RE
LOOKING FOR AN ASIAN AMERICAN
SHOW RUNNER SOMETIMES THEIR
SUPER SPECIFIC AND ASK ME FOR A
CHINESE FEMALE DRAMA SHOW
RUNNER. WHEN I RESPONDS WELL
THERE ARE TWO. I TELL THEM. AND
DIANA SON AND THEY'RE BOTH BUSY
MAY I RECOMMEND SOME KHLOE PEAS
OR OTHER EXECUTIVE PRODUCERS
WHO HAVE NOT BEEN SHOW RUNNERS
YET BUT WHO ARE READY. AND I
CONTINUALLY GET TURNED DOWN THE
ANSWER IS ALWAYS WELL WE REALLY
WANT SOMEONE WHO'S RUN A SHOW
BEFORE. THIS YEAR'S PILOT
SEASON THERE WERE AT LEAST SIX
ASIAN AMERICAN CENTER PILOTS
THAT WOULD HAVE HAD AN ASIAN
AMERICAN SHOW RUNNER. OF THOSE.
ONLY ONE SUNNY SIDE WAS ORDERED
TO SERIES. ON THE BRIGHT SIDE
THERE ARE A FEW NON ASIAN
AMERICAN CENTRIC PILOTS THAT
WERE ORDERED TO SERIES THAT
HAVE ASIAN AMERICAN SHOW
RUNNERS INCLUDING NANCY DREW
GREMLINS CENTRAL PARK
GENTRIFIED WU TANG ONE PIECE
AND A FEW OTHERS SOME OF WHICH
HAVE NOT BEEN ANNOUNCED YET. SO
THERE'S HOPE. AND ALSO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO. RUN AN ASIAN
AMERICANS SHOW IF YOU'RE A
GREAT WRITER AND A GOOD SHOWING
THERE COULD BE ANY SHOW. ON THE
FILM SIDE. THE TAX CREDIT THAT
YOU WORKED ON WAS FABULOUS AND
I KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING INTO THE
USE OF INCLUSION RIDERS.
ACCORDING TO THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA REPORT.
ASIANS OVER INDEX I'M GOING TO
THE MOVIES. IT'S TIME FOR MORE
FILMS TO REFLECT THE WORLD IN
WHICH WE LIVE. AND IT'S
INCUMBENT ON ALL OF US. AS
AUDIENCES TO SUPPORT THOSE
FILMS DURING OPENING WEEKENDS
WHICH WE ARE DOING THROUGH THE
GOLD OPEN MOVEMENT. THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
TO ADD MORE CRACKS TO THE GLASS
CEILING IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY. LET'S REACH THE
BREAKING POINT TOGETHER. AND.
MIKE THANK YOU MISLED. WHAT.
THE MORNING OF THE FIRST THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS SENATOR PAN SOME
REMEMBER BURN AND THAT SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE AND THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS FOR INVITING
ME HERE TODAY AND ALSO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE SUPPORT
YOU'VE OFFERED IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS. IN THAT A GNARLY TIME.
SO YOU FOR A LOT OF AGGRAVATE.
IT DOES STICK SO I'M HERE TODAY
TO SPEAK MORE FROM A PERSONAL
POINT OF VIEW AND FROM AN
INSIDER'S POINT OF VIEW IN
HOLLYWOOD. SO ONE OF THE FIRST
TELEVISION SHOWS I RODE ON I
CREATED A CHARACTER WHO WAS. A
DASHING LADIES MET SOMEONE WHO
HAD A DOMINANT PERSONALITY AT
WORK. AND I TOLD MY SHOWRUNNER
I WANTED AN ASIAN MAN TO PLAY
THIS PART. AND MY CHILDREN THEN
SAID HE COULDN'T SEE THAT TOO
BUT TO HIS CREDIT HE SAID TO GO
AHEAD IF I COULD FIND THE RIGHT
ACTOR FOR THE ROLE HE WOULD
SUPPORT IT. SO I SENT THE
CHARACTER DESCRIPTION FOR
CASTING DEPARTMENT AT THE
NETWORK. AND ONE OF THE FIRST
QUESTIONS THEY ASKED WAS CAN
YOU FEEL IT TINO OR AFRICAN
AMERICAN. AND WHEN I SAID NO
THE SENT US A HANDFUL OF HIS
LEAST ROUNDED UP ACTORS WHO
WERE NOWHERE CLOSE TO HITTING
THE MARK. THEY EXPLAINED THAT
THE KIND OF GOOD LOOKING
CHARMING TALENTED SEXUALLY
CONFIDENT ASIAN MALE I WAS
LOOKING FOR DID NOT EXIST. CAN
BE FOUND. THANKFULLY I WAS CO
WRITING THE SCRIPT WITH ANOTHER
ASIAN AMERICAN WRITER WHO TOOK
THIS VERY PERSONALLY AND
TOGETHER. WE PUSHED ON CASTING
AND REFUSED TO CONCEDE UNTIL
THEY FOUND IS THE RIGHT ACTOR.
DIG DEEPER. AND EVENTUALLY THEY
DID THE ACTOR WAS AMAZING
WONDERFUL THE EPISODE TURNED
OUT WELL AND HE BROUGHT SO MUCH
TO THE ROLE AND HE IS YOU KNOW
IT'S CONTINUED TO ACT AND STAR
IN. A BE FEATURED IN A
TELEVISION SERIES. THIS WAS
SIXTEEN YEARS AGO. AND SINCE
THEN I'VE WORKED ON A VARIETY
OF SHOWS BUT OFTEN I RUN INTO
THE SAME SITUATION AGAIN AND
AGAIN. ON ONE OF THE LAST SHOWS
I WAS ON WE HAD A VILLAIN
CHARACTER WHO WAS PHYSICALLY
AND PSYCHOLOGICALLY
INTIMIDATING. AND I WANTED TO
LOOK AT USING ACTORS FOR THE
PART AND THAT SHOW RUNNER SAID
YOU COULDN'T SEE IT. AND THIS
TIME HE DID NOT TO GIVE ME THE
GO AHEAD TO PURSUE THAT. SO
WHAT I WILL. THAT IF I WANT TO
CAST AN ASIAN ACTOR IN A PART.
THAT ISN'T GENERIC MUGGING
VICTIM NUMBER TWO OR STEER
TYPICALLY ASIAN NAIL SALON
WORKERS SEX TRAFFICKING VICTIM
FOR WOMEN. OR COMPUTER TECH
ENGINEER TRIAD MEMBER FOR MEN.
I WOULD GET VARYING DEGREES OF
PUSH BACK WHETHER IT'S FROM THE
SHOW RUNNERS CASTING A STUDIO
EXECUTIVES. NO ONE WOULD EVER
OPENLY SAY WE DON'T WANT TO
CAST ASIANS THAT WOULD JUST BE
A SILENCE OR I'D GET A LIST OF
POTENTIAL ACTORS WERE NOT
ASIAN. OR THEY SAY THEY WERE
ALL FOR PROMOTING DIVERSITY BUT
THE TALENT POOL SIMPLY ISN'T
THERE. THESE ARE BATTLES I. IN
OTHER API CREATORS ARE USED TO
FIGHTING. BUT EVEN WHEN WE DO
SUCCEED THAT VICTORY FEELS FAN.
THE PARTS MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
ARE FOR SMALLER ROLES. OF THE
DOZEN TV SHOWS I'VE WORKED ON
ALL THE LEAD ROLES WHAT WE CALL
NUMBER ONE ON THE CALL SHEET
OUR WHITE. AND FOR THAT MATTER
NUMBER TWO THREE AND SOMETIMES
FOUR WHITE. NUMBER FIVE
SOMETIMES AND THAT'S WHERE YOU
SORT OF BERRY LIKE YOU KNOW
DETECTIVE NUMBER FOUR AND YOU
KNOW THAT'S WHERE YOU GET YOUR
PERSON OF COLOR ON ON THAT TV
SHOW. I'M THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THERE HASN'T BEEN. THERE HAVE
BEEN MANY BREAK OUT MEANINGFUL
ROLES FOR API ACTORS. CENTER
AND KILLING EVE THE WHOLE CAST
OF FRESH OF THE BOAT J. CHOI
AND SINGLE PARENTS I JIM MILLER
JIM MAIL AND- MANY JUSTIN SO IN
A GOOD PLACE AND JUST TO NAME A
FEW. BUT WE SHOULD NOT TAKE
THIS PROGRESS FOR GRANTED.
STUDIOS STILL CLAIM THAT YOU'RE
PROMOTING DIVERSITY M.
VISIBILITY BY CASTING ASIANS IN
WHAT. YOU WOULD VIEW AS MINOR
AND SOMETIMES INTERCHANGEABLE
ROLES. AND THE TRUTH IS THOSE
TOKEN EFFORTS TO PROMOTE. IT TO
PROMOTE DIVERSITY YOU KNOW
ACTUALLY PROMOTES ANOTHER
DAMAGING NARRATIVE SWITCHES
ASIANS CAN BE BIT PLAYERS BUT
THEY ARE NOT THE HEROES OF THE
STORY. AND THIS BEGS THE
QUESTION WHY ISN'T THERE MORE
CONTENT FEATURING ASIAN LEADS
AND STORIES. FIRST ALTHOUGH AS
MITCHELL POINTED OUT THE
NUMBERS ARE IMPROVING THERE'S A
LACK OF API CONTENT CREATORS.
AND EVEN FOR THOSE OF US WHO
BECOME SUCCESSFUL SHOW RUNNERS
WRITERS DIRECTORS. DIRECTORS WE
FACE A GAUNTLET OF OBSTACLES
WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO GET OR
SELL SHOWS WITH LEADS WHO LOOK
LIKE US. I KNOW AND HAVE
COMMISERATE WITH SEVERAL
EXPERIENCE WELL REGARDED API
WRITERS WHO SUCCESSFULLY
SUCCESSFULLY RUN SHOWS WITH
WHITE LEADS BUT CAN'T LAUNCH
SHOWS WITH ASIAN LEADS. AND THE
CONSENSUS SEEMS TO BE THAT
AMONG THE DEVELOPMENT
EXECUTIVES AND PRODUCERS WHO
ARE OVERWHELMINGLY WHITE THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE STORIES
UNDERSTAND THE CULTURAL
SPECIFICITY AND BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T RELATE TO OUR STORIES. AS
A RESULT WE DON'T CHAMPION THEM.
THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS OF COURSE
THIS PAST YEAR WE'VE HAD A
WEALTH OF ASIAN DRIVEN MOVIE
HITS. SUCH AS TO ALL THE BOYS
OF LOVE BEFORE SEARCHING ALWAYS
BE MY MAYBE AND OF COURSE CRAZY
RICH ASIANS. WHICH TOGETHER
COLLECTIVELY PROVED MAINSTREAM
AMERICA IS READY AND
ENTHUSIASTIC TO C. API DRIVEN
CONTENT. THE STUDIO SYSTEM IS
SLOW TO ADAPT. AFTER THE BOX
OFFICE SUCCESS A CRAZY RICH
ASIANS THERE WAS TALK OF THIS
NEW ERA IN HOLLYWOOD AND THAT
THERE WAS A RECORD NUMBER OF
ASIAN DRIVEN PROJECTS BEING
PICKED UP. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT THAT WAS A YEAR AGO OF
THE NUMBER OF SHOWS THAT WERE
AT LEAST DEVELOPED. AS MITCHELL
POINTED OUT ONE WAS PICKED OUT
FOR NETWORK BROADCAST PRIMETIME.
THE BIGGER ISSUE. IS NOT JUST
GIVING OPPORTUNITIES TO ASIAN
ACTORS I THINK EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM KNOWS THAT. MOVIES AND TV
ARE A MIRROR TO AMERICA. I WAS
AN IMMIGRANT I GREW UP IN
MALAYSIA I CAME HERE WHEN I WAS
NINETEEN AND EVERYTHING I KNEW
ABOUT AMERICA WAS FROM MOVIES
IT'S WHY I WANTED TO COME TO
THIS COUNTRY TO BE PART OF
SOMETHING AMAZING. HAVING
WORKED IN IT I KNOW NOW IT IS A
DISTORTED MIRROR. ONE THAT HAS
SELECTIVELY IGNORE THE FACES
STORIES AND THE CONTRIBUTIONS
OF OUR COMMUNITY. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE SOLUTION IS BUT I DO
KNOW THAT IT STARTS WITH
SHINING A SPOTLIGHT ON THE DEEP
SYSTEMIC ISSUES FACING OUR
CREATIVE COMMUNITY TODAY.
CALLING OUT BY IS UNFAIR
BLATANTLY RACIST PRACTICES WHEN
WE SEE THEM. INSTEAD OF GOING
ALONG TO GET ALONG. AND PUTTING
PRESSURE ON THE STUDIOS TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL CHANGES. IN THE
PRACTICE IS TO PROMOTE
DIVERSITY AND NOT JUST PAYING
IT LIP SERVICE. IF THEY CLAIM
THEY CAN'T C. S. LET'S MAKE
SURE THE AT LEAST CAN HEAR US.
THANK YOU. QUESTIONS SERVER
CHOW JIM I COULD JUST FOLLOW UP
ON YOUR LAST COMMENT. AND THEN.
YEAH BY PUTTING PRESSURE ON THE
STUDIOS. YOU KNOW WHAT
SPECIFICALLY CAN WE DO I MEAN
AT YOU KNOW HE IS REFERRING TO
LET'S SAY AS A **** AS WE COULD
PROBABLY OF VOICE ALL CONCERNED
PROBABLY UP IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW THAT WE COULD CUT.
IT CANNOT DO AS AS AS A AS A AS
A BODY. ABSOLUTELY I. THERE WAS
MUCH OF THE TAX CREDIT STUDIOS
ABSOLUTELY RESPOND TO THE
PRESSURE FROM THE PUBLIC AND
PRESSURE FROM LAWMAKERS
PARTICULARLY WHEN THEIR TAX
INCENTIVES DANGLED IN FRONT OF
THEM AND I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT CAN BE IT PUT TO
THEM IS JUST TO IMPROVE THE
EXISTING NUMBERS. AND THAT
REALLY DOES COME FROM HIRING
API CONTENT CREATORS NOT JUST
SUPERFICIALLY BOOSTING THEIR
NUMBERS IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
LOWER LEVEL WRITERS ON TV SHOWS
THAT ARE BEING HIRED BECAUSE
WHEN YOU HIRE A WHEN YOU HIRE
AN API CONTENT CREATOR DIRECTOR
FOR FILM OR A SHOW RUNNER FOR
TELEVISION. THERE ARE CHANGES
UP AND DOWN THE RANKS WHETHER
IT'S IN CASTING AND CREW BEHIND
THE SCENES ALL OF THOSE NUMBERS
CHANGE AT AS A REACTION TO
THAT. NOW YOU MENTIONED I THINK
I THINK WAS MACHEL MENTION
ABOUT THE TAX CREDIT ANDY
INCLUSION WRITERS SO
SPECIFICALLY YOU KNOW AT THE
STATE LEVEL AT THE LEGISLATURE
LEVEL CAN YOU THINK OF ANY ANY
OTHER MEASURES THAT. WE COULD
TAKE ON IT AS AS A WHOLE. I
THINK IF WE CAN CONTINUE
PUSHING ON THOSE LEVERS THAT WE
HAVE AND- AND ALSO IF THERE'S
MORE EVEN JUST. SHINING THE
SPOTLIGHT SAYING WHAT ARE SOME
OF WHICH ARE YOUR NUMBERS OF
EXECUTIVES I DON'T THINK I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO FIND ANY STUDY.
AND MAYBE SOMEONE ON TODAY'S
PANEL WILL HOPEFULLY WE'LL DO A
STUDY AFTER TODAY WHAT DOES.
HOLLY WOULD SPECIFICALLY WHAT
IS THERE EXECUTIVE RANKS LOOK
LIKE IN TERMS OF THEIR- API
MAKE UP. SCOTT AND. SO MY CAR
THANK YOU THANK YOU BOTH FOR
THE WITH EVERYTHING YOU'VE BEEN
DOING I KNOW LET ME SHOW WHEN
SOME OF US MIKE **** HAD A
CHANCE TO MEET WITH YOU THE LOS
ANGELES WE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
THE INDUSTRY I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
A SHOW RUNNER WAS THE TIMES I'M
GLAD YOU ACTUALLY. THERE'S MORE
BUREAUCRACY IN HOLLYWOOD AND
POLITICS. THE GOVERNMENT. BUT
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH
AND YOU MENTIONED A TAX CREDIT
AND- THAT. CREDIT THE CREDIT
FOR GETTING THE TAX CREDIT AND
THAT CONVERSATION TO REALLY.
DOESN'T BELONG LEGISLATURE IT
BELONGS THE TWO OF YOU AND THE
OTHERS THAT REALLY CONTINUE TO
SPEAK UP AND HAVE BEEN FOR A
VERY LONG TIME. A VERY LONG
TIME. AND LET ME TALK ABOUT TO.
THAT ONE OF THE QUOTES THAT I
W. SAYS WE'RE ALL FOR DIVERSITY
BUT THE TOPPLE SIMPLY ISN'T
THERE. WE HEAR THAT A LOT. M.
AND WE HEAR THAT ACROSS THE
BOARD I THINK A LOT OF
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW WOMEN HERE
THAT. ALL THE TIME. BUT IF I
GET ESPECIALLY DODD BUT TRACK.
I GOT A LOT OF CONVERSATION TED
WHEN IT COMES AFTER MIKE LEFT
IN THIS THAT. TOPPLED AS THEIR
AND HOLLY WOULD CERTAINLY I
THINK A NUMBER. OF MINORITY
GROUPS AS WELL AS WOMEN HERE
THAT OFTEN TIMES. AND IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE IT'S A TOTALLY
UNACCEPTABLE AND. SO WHAT I
SAY. IS THEN YOU CREATE THE
TALENT POOL. AS THE PEOPLE ARE
THERE THE TALENTS THERE. AND SO
PART OF IT IS CERTAINLY AN
IMPLICIT BIAS WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN.
DEALING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
THIS YEAR ALONE ONE OF ONE OF
OUR COLLEAGUES WHILE THEY- HAD
THREE DIFFERENT TWO DIFFERENT
BILLS. THAT HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
BUT THE COURT SYSTEM CANNELLA
JUST SYSTEM OF THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. IN TERMS OF TRAINING ON
IMPLICIT BIAS THAT MIGHT BE A
DIRECTION. WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY AS
WELL. BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST A
MATTER. OF THE NUMBERS. IT'S
ALSO A MATTER OF HOW WE'RE
PORTRAYED. AND MIKE YOU COME
HERE AND THE TV AND MOVIES AND-
WHEN YOU SEE HIGHER PERPETRATED
END UP BEING BULLIED BECAUSE-
HOW. IN MY CASE INDIANS OF A
TRADE ON TV. AND IT'S JUST. YOU
KNOW TO THINK ABOUT. HOW FAR
WE'VE COME AND HELP OUT WE
HAVEN'T COME. AND SO YOU KNOW
WHEN IT COMES TO PORTRAYAL SO
THE ONE THING IS THE NUMBERS
AND THE OTHER THING IS OUR PRE
TRADE. HOW CAN WE MOVE ON ON
THAT ISSUE OF POWER FOR TRADE.
NOT SIMPLY JUST HOW MAY WHAT
THE NUMBERS. ARE WHICH IS
SOMETHING WE ALL AGREE NEEDS TO
IMPROVE AS WELL. I'M IN TERMS
OF HOW WE ARE PORTRAYED IT.
DOES REALLY GO BACK TO HAVING A
PI. CONTENT CREATE. BECAUSE
THERE IS. WHAT WE DO IS SO
SUBJECTIVE. AND THERE IS A PREP
THE PROBLEM IDEA THAT WHITE
MALE SHOW RUNNERS WHITE MALE
FEATURE WRITERS CAN WRITE FOR
ANYBODY. WHERE AS WE ARE
RELEGATED TO ONLY WRITE NEEDS
ONLY WRITING FOR YOU KNOW OUR
COMMUNITY. AND I DON'T HAVE TO
TELL THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
BUT YOU KNOW YOU NEED TO HAVE
WALKED IN THOSE SHOES TO BE
ABLE TO WRITE FROM THAT
CHARACTER FOR THAT CHARACTER.
TO PROVIDE AN AUTHENTIC POINT
OF VIEW A UNIQUE WORLD VIEW
THERE'S NOTHING THAT REALLY
EXPO REPLACES. LIFE EXPERIENCE
AND AGAIN I WANT TO LIVE IN THE
IDEAL WORLD WHERE EVERYONE CAN
RIGHT FOR EVERYONE BUT THAT
COMES WITH HAVING A GREAT
UNDERSTANDING AND APPRECIATION
AND AFFECTION FOR THAT CULTURE.
AND A LOT OF TIMES IT'S SIMPLY
NOT THERE YOU KNOW FOR A LOOK
FOR A LOT OF THESE WRITERS. SO
I WOULD SAY THAT IN TERMS OF
HOW WE ARE PORTRAYED WHEN I
TALK ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE OF
SHOW RUNNERS SAYING YOU KNOW I
JUST CAN'T SEE THAT. YEAH RIGHT
SPECIFICALLY FROM THEIR POINT
OF VIEW OF GROWING UP IN YOU
KNOW A WEALTHY SUBURB ON THE
EAST COAST HAVING GONE TO A
REALLY GREAT SCHOOL AND YOU
KNOW THERE ONE CIRCLE OF
FRIENDS IF THEY DON'T SEE.
PEOPLE OF COLOR YOU KNOW WHAT.
OCCUPY A CERTAIN SPACE IN THEIR
LIVES THEY DON'T NEED IT AND IT
DOES MATTER THAT WE ON STAFF
HAVE C. HAVE THOSE PEOPLE GREW
UP WITH THOSE PEOPLE HAVE TO
TAKE OUR WORD FOR IT BECAUSE
WHAT WE DO IS SUBJECT IF THEY
CAN CHOOSE NOT. SO REALLY IT IS
A BOTTOM AND YOU KNOW THE
AMAZING. THE I. WRITERS AND-
WRITERS WHO ARE. TO GO OUT AND
DEVELOP AND SELL. FROM THE
STUDIOS PICK UP THOSE SHOWS
BECAUSE AGAIN BECAUSE THERE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME SUMMER
CAMP EXPERIENCES AS WE DO WITH
THE FAMILY EXPERIENCES YOU KNOW
THE IT'S LESS LIKELY FOR AN
EXECUTIVE OR SOMEONE WITH
GREENLIGHT POWER TO SAVE I LOVE
THAT STORY I HAD THAT
EXPERIENCE I'M GOING TO BACK IT
ALL THE WAY THAT THE CHANCES OF
THAT HAPPENING WITH ONE OF OUR
PROJECT IS MUCH MUCH LOWER.
IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S FUNNY IS
ALMOST COMICAL TO ME THAT
THAT'S THIS. IT'S LIKE WOMEN
PEOPLE COLOR WE HAVE THE CODES
WHICH ALL THE TIME WE HAVE NO
LEGAL UNDER ROOM. HOW DO WE
HAVE TO CHANGE OURSELVES TO BE
ACCEPTED IN THAT ROOM. AND
WHITE MAN ON THE TOTEM POLE
APART ON THE BOTTOM OF THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO C.
PERSPECTIVE OTHER PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THE SOCIETY WHERE. SO
BUT IT'S NOT UNUSUAL THAT'S THE
NORM I THINK IN MANY INDUSTRIES
WHERE. THE NORMATIVE
PERSPECTIVE IS THE WHITE MALE
PERSPECTIVE. BUT YOU THINK THAT
ENTERTAINMENT. IT'S JUST THE
FACT THAT THAT'S THE NORM IN
ANY INDUSTRY IS COMICAL. BUT IN
ENTERTAINMENT WHEN YOU REALLY
WANT TO TRY TO. HAVE
INTERESTING STORIES AND I SEE
ALL THESE NEW SHOWS COMING OUT
IT'S THE SAME. KIND OF SAME
KIND OF EITHER DRAMA OR SIT COM
WITH ALL WHITE MILK WHAT WHAT
ALL WHITE CAST. THE SAME THING
THEY JUST REGURGITATE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN SO I JUST SAW AN
INTERESTING. I JUST LIKE TO ADD
ONE OF A SMALL NOTE TO THE IS
THAT THE THRESHOLD OF. THERE IS
ALSO DIFFERENT FOR US. IN ANY
GIVEN YEAR WE HAVE A LOT OF.
PILOTS THAT YOU WILL NEVER SEE
YOU KNOW THEY'LL TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT AND WHEN IT IS AS YOU KNOW
A SHOW RUNNER WITH. A WHITE
SHOW AND IT FEELS IT'S WELL THE
CHEMISTRY WASN'T RIGHT YOU KNOW
YOU CAN'T GET IT RIGHT. TIME.
BUT IF YOU ARE AN AGENT JANET
SURE MINE. DRIVEN. VERSUS YOU
KNOW IT THEY COULD HAVE. AGAIN
WHAT WE DO. SO SUBJECTIVE IT'S
IT IT'S AN ALCHEMY ALMOST AND
SO YOU KNOW IT. IT REALLY HURTS
THE- THE WHOLE THE CAUSE OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO. WHEN
OUR RACE BECOMES THE WITH M.
THE REASON FOR THE FAILURE.
RENTED PIGGYBACKING ON THAT
THAT MAKES THE- WINDOW.
EXTREMELY SMALL BECAUSE THE
BARRIER TO ENTRY IS SO HIGH FOR
US. NOW IS TO GET THERE WHEN
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO FAIL AND
THEN WHEN WE DO IT'S NOT LIKE
JUST CLOSES. I HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT OUT THIS PAST WEEKEND I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE A
PART OF THE PRE SCREENING OF
THE- THE UPCOMING MOVIE D.
ABOMINABLE. WHICH BASICALLY IS
THE FIRST ANIMATED MOVIE.
FEATURING AN ASIAN CAST I GUESS
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE PROMISED.
AND I YEAH I TOOK YOU KNOW TOOK
A LOOK AT IT AND WAS VERY. VERY
MOVING IN IN IN MANY YOU KNOW A
GREAT RESPECT. AND MY QUESTION
TO YOU IS DO YOU FOR C. R. MORE
OF THAT SIMILAR KIND OF. WORK
BEING PUT OUT THERE I YEAH I
MET SOME OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO. WERE PART OF THE DEAL THE
WORK AND I WAS EXCITED BECAUSE
I SEE. HEY LOOK YOU KNOW WE
HAVE HOPE YET SO YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS RIGHT AFTER A
CRAZY CRAZY WHICH ASIAN. BUT SO
I YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE GONNA
PREVIEW IN ABOUT TWO WEEKS OR
SO BUT BUT SO YOU SEE. MORE
WORK LIKE THAT COMING COMING UP.
ACTUALLY WORKING ON A DISNEY
ANIMATED FEATURE RIGHT NOW THAT
IS IT'S A FANTASY. IT'S A
FANTASY WORLD BUT INSPIRED BY
SOUTHEAST ASIA AND WE WILL HAVE
AN ALL ASIAN CAST AND GO WITH
AN EMPHASIS ON AS SOUTHEAST
ASIA AS WELL. SO YOU KNOW IT IF
IT BUT IT'S ONE PROJECT I CAN'T
SPEAK TO PROMISING THAT THERE
WILL BE MORE AND I THINK THAT'S
PART OF. THE DISCUSSION AS
WELL. AFTER CRAZY RICH THERE
WAS THAT FEELING THAT WELL
THINGS ARE CHANGING WE DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
ANYMORE. BUT THE THING TO BEAR
IN MIND WAS WEAK BUT THE FIRST
ALL ASIAN CAST CONTEMPORARY
HOLLYWOOD MOVIE AND THE LAST
WAS JOY LUCK CLUB WHICH WAS
TWENTY FIVE. YEARS AGO SO
THAT'S A LONG TIME IN COMING
AND SO WHILE I'M EXCITED TO BE
WORKING ON THIS MOVIE. AND HOPE
THAT THERE WILL BE A LOT MORE I
THINK WE SHOULD NEVER TAKE FOR
GRANTED THAT. THIS JUST SHOWS A
CHANGING TIDE AND THAT'S JUST
HOW THE FACTORY IS GOING TO
MOVE FROM THIS POINT FORWARD. I
THINK IT'S CONSTANT VIGILANCE
AND CONSTANTLY YOU KNOW
FIGHTING KEEPING AN EYE ON IT.
THANKS. I JUST I HAVE A
QUESTION. SO WE I THINK A LOT
OF IT IN TERMS OF YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE HOLLYWOOD CULTURE AND
WHAT WE CAN TRY TO DO TO CHANGE
THAT BUT IN TERMS OF. BEYOND
THE FILM TAX CREDIT YOU KNOW WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THE PURCHASING
POWER OF THE API COMMUNITY I
THINK IN ENTERTAINMENT OR
STREET OR SOME INTEREST AS WELL
AS YOU KNOW TERMS OF PROFITS
COMING FROM OVERSEAS AND SO
FORTH. IS WHAT WAY KIM IS OUR
OPPORTUNITIES OR LACK OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO THAT ON THE
FINANCING AND IN TERMS OF THE
PURCHASING POWER OF API PEOPLE
INVEST WHO API WHO ELSE WHO IS
DESTINED ENTERTAINMENT AND SO
FORTH TO BASICALLY LEVERAGE
THAT TO GET MORE CREATIVES TO
DEMAND MORE PEOPLE OUR SHOW
RUNNERS AND OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS A IS THERE AN
OPPORTUNITY THERE OR IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW AS WE
THINK ABOUT CROSS SECTORS HOW
DO WE PUT PRESSURE ON THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY SAY NO
ACTUALLY WE WANT TO HAVE PEOPLE
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE'RE NOT TO
PUT OUR MONEY THERE. I REMAIN
THE CALL OF. A FEW YEARS AGO
THERE WAS SOME TIGHT WITH. ONE
OF THE IMMIGRATION LEASES THAT
IF PEOPLE INVEST FROM OVERSEAS
INCHES LIKE A REAL ESTATE
PROJECTS OR A FILM PROJECT THEN
THEY COULD THAT WOULD HELP THEM
GET A VISA I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT. STILL EXISTS TODAY. IS
THAT A BUFFET. FIVE YEAH. I
KNOW THAT OKAY I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S SOME KIND OF TIED AT
THAT COULD BE LIKE ACROSS
SECTORS THING. PERHAPS RICHARD.
EVERY THOUGHT MANY TERMS OF I
YEAH YOU HAVE TO HI ARE YOU
THERE AND THEN THE PEOPLE ARE
FINANCING THESE PROJECTS SO IS
I MEAN D. C. THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES AND- WHAT. I
THINK IN THE ABOMINABLE EXAMPLE
IS VERY GOOD DOES IT
COPRODUCTION BETWEEN DREAMWORKS
AND PRO STUDIO AND SO I THINK
WE'RE GONNA SEE A LOT MORE.
CHINESE CO PRODUCTIONS COMING
DOWN AND I MEAN IF A BOMB LARA
DOES WELL THE NEXT ONE IS OVER
THE MOON AND THEY'VE GOT A
WHOLE SLATE. LINED UP THAT THEY
CAN KEEP MAKING THESE FILMS AS
LONG AS THEY DO WELL IN THE BOX
OFFICE AGAIN TURNS BACK TO. THE
REST OF US TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE SUPPORTING IT OPENING
WEEKEND. BUT I DON'T KNOW HOW
IT WORKS WITH THE CO
PRODUCTIONS AND IF THERE'S ANY
LEVERS THAT YOU CAN PUNCH. ON
THAT END. AND ANY THOUGHTS FROM
FROM THE POSITION AS A WRITER
IS THAT IT EVEN IN THE IN THE
UNIVERSE OR IS THAT JUST.
FINANCE IS I'M OUT OF MY DEPTH
THEY WAS WHAT MY MOTHER WANTS
ME TO MAJOR IN IN COLLEGE AND I
SADLY I DID NOT I JUST BECAME A
WRITER. BUT IT YOU KNOW I FROM
A PERSONAL POINT OF VIEW IN
TERMS OF WHAT STUDIOS ARE
AFFECTED BY IT REALLY. IT'S SAD
TO SAY I WISH IT WASN'T THE
CASE BUT IT IS A LOT OF TIMES
YOU KNOW EITHER PUBLIC SHAMING
OR SOMEHOW YOU KNOW. INCENTIVES
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD
THEIR PRODUCTIONS YOU KNOW
LOCALLY BETTER AT LEAST WORK AT
LEAST FOR CALIFORNIA YEAH THAT
WAS A LOT OF GRUMBLING IT. A
LOT OF DOCTORS USED TO BE
CENTERED IN LOS ANGELES AROUND
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE LOSING A
LOT OF THAT TO ATLANTA TO YOU
KNOW NINE NORTH AND- I THINK
LIKE SOUTH CAROLINA. LOUISIANA
AND THERE IS THAT APPS
ABSOLUTELY THAT INTEREST IN
LIKE YOU KNOW PULLING THE
PULLING PRODUCTION BACK TO
CALIFORNIA. SO I FEEL LIKE
THAT'S ALWAYS A GOOD AREA.
TERMS OF LEVERAGE OKAY GREAT. I
THINK THERE IS SET UP OKAY GET
ALL AREA THAT THAT'S ONE AREA
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY FURTHER
EXPLORED YET YOU KNOW THAT
REQUIRES COAL PRODUCTION I
THINK WE CAN PROBABLY HELP OUT
TO SOME EXTENT DEPENDING ON
WHAT IT IS BUT IF THAT'S WERE
YOU KNOW WERE THE ACTION COULD
BEAT AND YOU KNOW WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO HELP OUT IN FACT A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THE SPEAKER
AND I PLAYED A DELEGATION TO
CHINA TO BASICALLY PROMOTE.
EXCHANGES BETWEEN YOU KNOW IN A
FEMINIST BETWEEN THE TWO
BETWEEN FORTY AND CHINA AND SO
YOU KNOW ALONG THE WAY WE FOUND
OUT SOME OF THE RESTRICTIONS
THAT WERE PLACED ON FOLKS WHO
WANT TO INVEST IN CHINA AND
VICE VERSA SO YOU KNOW THE
OBJECTIVE WAS TO ESSENTIALLY
TO. KIND OF HELP PROMOTE OR YOU
KNOW THE FACILITATOR TO I
ENTITIES SO YOU THINK OF
ANYTHING THAT WE COULD KIND OF
HELP. OUT YOU KNOW MORE
SPECIFIC PLEASE LET US KNOW
ALSO. OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH THANK YOU I
THINK I THINK. RIGHT OKAY SO
NEXT UP IS OUR PAN ON
JOURNALISM AND I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME TED HAN THE NATIONAL
VICE PRESIDENT ON FINANCE FOR
THE ASIAN AMERICAN JOURNALISTS
ASSOCIATION. TED HOW IS A
CONSOLE THAT ENTREPRENEUR HE
HAS WORKED WITH NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS IN JOURNALISM NOT
PROFITS AROUND THE WORLD AND
CURRENTLY SERVES AS A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE EIGHT AN AMERICAN
JOURNAL. C. H. AND ACTUALLY AND
BETH YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU TO SENATOR PAN IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR INVITING US HERE
I'M JULIE P. CHAN I AM THE
MANAGING EDITOR OF DIGITAL AT
KQED WHICH IS THE LARGEST
PUBLIC MEDIA ORGANIZATION HERE
IN CALIFORNIA I ALSO SERVE ON
THE NATIONAL BOARD OF THE ASIAN
AMERICAN JOURNALISTS
ASSOCIATION AND M. IN THE PRESS
AND M. THE PRESIDENT OF THE
LOCAL BAY AREA CHAPTER. THIS IS
TED HAN AND EVERY CAN HEAR ME
ALRIGHT AS SENATOR PAN SAID I
DO SUFFER CONSULTING I'M ALSO
ON THE NATIONAL BOARD AND I
HAVE WORKED WITH THESE
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE WORLD
FOR THE PAST EIGHT YEARS SIX OF
THOSE. WITH A JOURNAL THE NOT
FOR PROFIT INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTERS AND EDITORS. OKAY
HELLO TO BOTH OF YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SO JUST A
LITTLE BACKGROUND ON THE ASIAN
AMERICAN JOURNALISTS
ASSOCIATION WHICH WILL BE
REFERRING TO AS AJ IT WAS
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
WHICH IS EASY FOR ME TO
REMEMBER BECAUSE THAT'S ALSO MY
AIR. TO CREATE A COMMUNITY OF
SUPPORT FOR JOURNALISTS OF
ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER BACKGROUNDS. THE
ORGANIZATION RECOGNIZED EARLY
ON THAT JOURNALISTS NEED TO
SUPPORT AT EVERY LEVEL OF THEIR
CAREER FROM EXPIRING
JOURNALISTS IN HIGH SCHOOL
COLLEGE EARLY CAREER MADE
CAREER. THOSE LOOKING TOWARDS
LEADERSHIP AND THOSE FEW OF US
THERE WERE FORTUNOFF TO ACHIEVE
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS. SO AJ
REALLY IDENTIFIED THIS PROBLEM
WITH THE DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION IN THE JOURNALISM
INDUSTRY PRETTY EARLY ON AND
TRIES TO ADDRESS IT THROUGH
PROGRAMMING AND STRATEGY WHICH
IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY.
STRATEGY AND OUTRAGE SO TODAY
WE WANT TO ADDRESS THE FACT
THAT THE NEEDLE HAS MOVED VERY
LITTLE ON THE DESERT DIVERSITY
INCLUSION FRONTS IN THE
JOURNALISM INDUSTRY IN THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS. BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT'S AT STAKE ULTIMATELY IS
THE COVERAGE OF OUR COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND OUR
CAREER TRAJECTORIES WHICH WILL
GET A LITTLE BIT MORE INTO AS
FAR AS HOW MESSY IT IS
ESPECIALLY ADDITIONAL SPACE
WHAT I REALLY APPRECIATED ABOUT
THE ENTERTAINMENT PANEL WAS
THAT HIERARCHY. OF THE TV'S
WRITERS GROUP. I WANT THAT FOR
THE DIGITAL SPACE I THINK YOU
KNOW NOT ONLY HAS OUR INDUSTRY
BEEN DISRUPTED BY YOU KNOW A
VERY BUSINESS ORIENTED
CHALLENGES AS FAR AS FINDING A
SUSTAINABLE BUSINESS MODEL
DECLINING AD DOLLARS. BUT ALSO
AT THE TECH INNOVATIONS THAT
HAVE HAPPENED AND LEGACY
ORGANIZATIONS NEEDING TO PAVE
IT OR MORE DIGITAL START UPS
KIND OF SPROUTING UP WE DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING NICE AND NEAT
LIKE THAT SO WE'RE STILL VERY
MUCH MAPPING OUT. TRAJECTORIES
FOR FOLKS AND WHAT CAREERS CAN
LOOK LIKE. THAT ACTUALLY IS
REFLECTED IN THE DATA THAT
WE'VE GOT OUR M. OUR INDUSTRY
RELIES ON A SURVEY BY THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF NEWS
EDITORS WHICH THEY STARTED
COLLECTING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. AND THAT THE SERVICE
CHANGE A LITTLE BIT OVER THAT
TIME BUT BROADLY SPEAKING THE
SERVER NUMBERS INDICATE THAT.
IT IN IN BOTH AGGREGATE AND IN
PROPORTION THE INDUSTRY HASN'T
REALLY MADE A SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS OVER THE PAST THIRTY
YEARS. AND SOME YOU KNOW THERE
ARE A FEW BRIGHT SPOTS AND
THERE ARE NEWS ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE MADE IMPROVEMENTS
OVER THAT TIME. BUT GENERAL
CHANGES IN THE INDUSTRY AND-
REALLY LEAVE LARGE GAPS AND
HOLES YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT DOES
IT MEAN AT THE WASHINGTON POST
HAS IMPROVED THEIR DIVERSITY
NUMBERS. TO PEOPLE LIVING IN
STOWE OR YOU KNOW TENAQUIP. I'M
AND- ARE ARE REALLY LARGE
CHALLENGE IS HOW DO WE THINK
ABOUT COVERAGE AND JUST THE WAY
THAT THE INDUSTRY HAS REALLY
CHANGED. WE HAVE SEEN A GENERAL
COLLAPSE OF LOCAL REPORTING.
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS AS
BUSINESS MODELS OF SHIFTED FROM
NEWSPAPERS AND LOCAL TV
STATIONS TO ONLINE LET'S. AND
WHERE THAT DOLLARS EVERY ONE OF
BINGE GOOD LUCK TECH COMPANY. A
FEW COMPANIES THAT HAVE MANAGED
TO MAKE THAT. AND SO THAT THE
TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE ABOUT IN THE
SAME PLACES WHEN WE STARTED
COLLECTING DATA. THERE'S A PEAK
IN THE MID. TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND FIVE THROUGH TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WHERE THERE IS A
SLIGHT BUMP BUTTON THAT WE JUST
ACTUALLY REGRESSED SINCE THEN.
SO I WISH I HAD BETTER NEWS ON
THAT FRONT BUT YOU KNOW THIS
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE QUESTIONS
THAT MAKE A REALLY BIG
DIFFERENCE AT THE LOCAL AND
STATE LEVEL. IN TERMS OF WHAT
SORTS OF STORIES GET TOLD WHO
IS TELLING THEM AND YOU KNOW
HOW THEY WERE AT AT THE EXTENT
TO WHICH THEY ACCURATELY
REFLECT THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE LIVING. AROUND THE STATE.
OKAY THANK YOU. A QUESTION THAT
SOME MEMBERS OUT. OF CHURCH
JUST A COUPLE. FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS SO IN LIGHT OF THE
CHANGING. LANDSCAPE OF
PUBLICATION I II GOING ONLINE
FOR THE MOST PART. SO DO YOU
SEE A DWINDLING OF API'S WHO
WANT TO ENTER THAT. YOUR
PROFESSION TO BEGIN WITH NO
CERTAINLY NOT AND ACTUALLY. WE
SOME BRIGHT PRADA HISTORY. OKAY
AND ACTUALLY THE ASIAN AMERICAN
JOURNALISTS ASSOCIATION WE'RE
WE'RE BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO
ONE OF OUR VP'S FROM YEARS PAST
ACTUALLY WROTE A HISTORY OF THE
FIRST FIFTEEN YEARS. AND
ESSENTIALLY ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY TALK ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES ARE EXACTLY THE SAME
NOW AS AS WHEN THIS WAS WRITTEN
FIFTY AND- I GUESS ACTUALLY
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO I'M NOT
INCLUDES REPRESENTATION AMONGST
STUDENTS WHO ARE INTERESTED.
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND THEN
PEOPLE WHO ARE ENTERING THE
THAT THE INDUSTRY FOR THE FIRST
TIME THIS NAME NUMBERS HAVE
STAYED STABLE FOR YEARS. AND
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS WE WERE
JUST READING AN EXCERPT FROM
NINETEEN NINETY THAT TALKS
ABOUT THE SAME PROBLEM WE HAVE
NOW ACROSS INDUSTRIES WHICH IS
THAT WE ARE BEING HIRED. BUT
WE'RE NOT BEING PROMOTED WE'RE
NOT BEING EMPOWERED WERE NOT
BEING ELEVATED AND EITHER
THROUGH CONVERSATIONS AND
THROUGH COMMUNITY BUILDING JUST
IN THE JOURNALIST COLOR SPACE.
YOU FOUND THAT THERE IS A
THREAD A M. THAT MOST JOURNALS
OF COLOR FOR REALLY FEEL
ACUTELY ESPECIALLY IN THE
DIGITAL. BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE IN
A NON TRADITIONAL ROLE WHICH
JOEL SPACES RIFE UP WITH BROOKE
PRODUCERS. DATE OF FOLKS
DEVELOPERS THOSE NON
TRADITIONAL ROLES NOT THAT PORT
AT THE END OF THEY'RE OFTEN NOT
MIGHT NOT REDDIT. AND SO THE
PROJECT RESULT REALLY MURKY
THERE'S A PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY
THEY KNOW WHAT THEIR FUTURE
COULD BE IN THE INDUSTRY AND SO
FOLKS WILL LEAVE. NOT KNOWING
YOU KNOW WHAT IF YOU'RE IN THIS
INDUSTRY COULD LOOK LIKE. SO
SAID WHAT THEY ARE SAYING HERE
IS ABOUT THE GLASS CEILING YOU
SAID THAT BEGAN IN JOURNALISM.
ALL THE OTHER FIELDS PEOPLE GET
AP I GET HIRED. THEY'LL GET
PROMOTED WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
SO YOU TALKED ABOUT THE LEAST
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO DIGITAL
SPACE THERE'S LESS OF A CLEAR
PATH AS WELL. ALTHOUGH ONE
WOULD ARGUE I MEAN THAT THAT
IT'S THE PATH IS CLEAR NO
MATTER WHAT YOUR RACE IS SO
WHAT WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
PARTICULARLY BLOCKING API FROM
GETTING PROMOTED IN JOURNALISM
IS THAT STEREOTYPES ABOUT. OUR
YEAH ABOUT API AND OUR PEOPLE
SKILLS PERHAPS ARE ARE WHAT
WHAT WHAT IS IT THAT IN THE
JOURNAL OF SPACE THAT KEEPS API
FROM FROM MOVING UP IN THE
RANKS. I'M THERE ARE. LET'S SEE
HOW ABBAS FOR THIS IT. WHAT ONE
OF THE THINGS WITH THERE'S THE
SORT OF GENERAL QUESTION OF
LIKE HOW LARGE THE PIE IS AS
WELL I MEAN JUST THE NUMBER OF
OPPORTUNITIES AS OKAY
DECREASED. AND THAT THAT MEANS
THAT THE COUPLE COMPETITION IS
FEARS AND THE QUESTION IS WHAT
DO PEOPLE RELY UPON WHEN
THEY'RE ACTUALLY. RECRUITING
FOR CANDIDATES IN LOOKING FOR
FULL AND SO THERE'S EVEN BEEN
DISCUSSIONS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
ABOUT YOU KNOW PEOPLE RELYING
ON PEOPLE OF I BELIEVE WE GET
TO CATIONS RIGHT. AND SO THE
AND THE DIVERSITY CHALLENGES
THAT YOU SEE IN THOSE PLACES
ACTUALLY ALSO WE EXACERBATE OUR
OUR. CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF
HIRING PROMOTING. AND YOU KNOW
WHERE EVEN. WHERE DO WHAT
WHAT'S OUR ROLES TO DO ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
AND UP IN AND THERE'S A ISSUES
WITHIN THE INDUSTRY IN TERMS OF
DIVERSITY BEING SLOTTED INTO
FELLOWSHIP POSITIONS WHICH ARE
OFTEN PAID LESS THAN THE
STAFFER. AND THEN THE QUESTION
IS WHAT WHAT'S THE PROMOTION
TRACK OUT OF THAT ANDERSON SO
YOU ADDING ANOTHER WRONG ON THE
BOTTOM FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO CLIMB UP. OKAY
DIVERSITY IS OFTEN TREATED AS
THIS SEPARATE TOPIC ALMOST
LITERAL JOURNALISM SPACE. I'M
NOT SURE IF IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF OUR WORK THAT WE LIKE
TO PUT THINGS IN. TOPIC AREAS
AND BUCKETS AND WHAT NOT BUT
EVEN AT SOME OF OUR JOURNALISM
CONFERENCES YOU'LL FIND THERE'S
A DIVERSITY TRACK. THAT
COMPETES WITH DATA JOURNALISM
THAT COMPETES WITH
INVESTIGATIVE AND SO IF YOU'RE
A JOURNALIST TRYING TO. LEVEL
UP YOU HAVE TO PICK BETWEEN
DIVERSITY AND INVESTIGATIVE
SKILLS LIKE THAT'S THAT'S A
REALLY ODD CONFLICT THAT'S KIND
OF HAPPENING THAT WE SEE. IN
THE IN A VERY TANGIBLE WAY. I
THINK ANOTHER VERY SPECIFIC
THING THAT I'VE LOOKED AT
PERSONALLY IS HIRING PROCESS
HIRING PRACTICES. SO IT'D LEE.
TOM AND ALICE HAVE A VERY
DEMANDING JOB AND IF YOU'RE
HIRING ON TOP OF IT. THAT'S
ANOTHER DUTY ON TOP OF FULL
TIME JOB SO TO THE CREDIT OF A
LOT OF FOLKS I'VE SPOKEN TO IN
LEADERSHIP I THINK. ANALYZING
WHAT THAT MEANS AND HOW THAT
PLAYS OUT HAS BEEN A REALLY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS MEANING IF
YOU'RE TOO BUSY TO HIRE WHAT
SHORT CUTS TO YOU TAKE. AND IF
LEADERSHIP IN JOURNALISM IS NOT
DIVERSE WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
THEN WHEN FOLKS UP TOP. OUR
DIVERSE. OUR MAJORITY WHITE.
AND THEY'RE TAKING SHORT CUTS.
THAT MEANS THAT ULTIMATELY THE
FOLKS BEING HIRED ARE MOST
LIKELY GOING TO LEÓN THAT WAY
FROM DIVERSE CANADA THEY'RE
RELYING ON THEIR NETWORKS WORD
IS NOW IF YOU KNOW PEOPLE THEY
CAN TRUST THAT THEY BELIEVE
THEY CAN TRUST TO GET THE JOB
DONE AND THE QUESTION IS. ARE
YOU ACTUALLY RUNNING A PROCESS
THAT GIVES ALL APPLICANTS. SORT
OF AN EQUAL SHOT AT GETTING
THOSE ROLES SO SOME NEW IDEAS
AND THESE ARE EXACTLY RIGHT AS
FOR SOME IDEAS. LORD I'VE
WORKED VERY WELL IS YOU KNOW
COULD YOU COULD YOU BE A
DEVELOPING A HIRING COMMITTEE
THAT SUPPORTS THIS HIRING
MANAGER WHO IS ADMITTEDLY A
SHORT ON TIME. AND RESOURCES
AND CAN THEY GIVE JUST A LARGER
RANGE OF PERSPECTIVE. TO A
CANDIDATE POOL MEETING YOU. I.
ACTIVE ALL CANADA. THEY
RECOGNIZE THE MORE OBSCURE
PUBLICATION FOLKS WHO NO THIS
PERSON TO DO SOMETHING THAT WAS
A LITTLE BIT MORE OFF THE WALL
AND NOT IN THE TRADITIONAL KIND
OF BUCKET OF JOURNALISM SELLS
AND IN ORDER TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
AND JUST GIVE ALL OF A LARGER
RANGE OF PERSPECTIVE TO THAT
CONVERSATION AND SO HIRING
COMMITTEES THAT DIVERSITY
COMMITTEES THOSE HAVE BEEN
SOMETHING THAT HAVE WORKED WELL
TO TACKLE THIS REALLY SPECIFIC
PROBLEM BUT I THINK RETENTION
OF RISING RETENTION ARE STILL
VERY MUCH. BOB PROBLEMS AND
WE'RE DEALING WITH WE SEE THAT
EVEN WITHIN AJ COMMUNITY WHERE
SOME OF OUR CHAPTER LEADERS OF
PEOPLE WHO LEFT THE INDUSTRY
THEY THEY'RE STILL IMPORTANT
RESOURCES FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
YOU STARTING THEIR CAREER
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN AROUND FOR
A LITTLE WHILE BUT THE FACT
THAT THEY DON'T SEE A PLACE FOR
THEMSELVES. IN IN THE END. I'M
A- DISTRICT. AND WHEN THE OTHER
AGAIN WITH THE SHRINKING OF THE
PIE IS YOU KNOW. CITIES USED TO
HAVE TWO NEWSPAPERS AND SO YOU
KNOW IF YOUR WRITER THAN MAYBE
COULD BETH BETWEEN THEM BUT
THERE'S ONLY ONE PLACE. THE
ONLY SO MANY SLOTS TO LIVE IN
THAT COMMUNITY AND SO YOU KNOW
AND ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS
ABOUT THAT AND I SHOULD MENTION
ABOUT THE S. ANY SURVEY IS THAT
WE THE DIRECTION THE
INDUSTRY'S. HEADED IS HOW YOU
BEST HOW DO YOU HOW DO WE
REPRESENT THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
AS REFLECTED IN THE CENSUS OF
THEIR ACTUAL ACTION TRYING
WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO A PLACE
WHERE THE NEWS ROOM LITERALLY
DOES REFLECT THE COMMUNITIES.
WHERE STILL OTHER. QUESTION
ABOUT STEREO TYPES IN A I THINK
LEADERSHIP TRAINING IS ALSO
ANOTHER REALLY EFFECTIVE WAY
TO. TACKLE PART OF THIS
PROBLEM. AND IN THAT. CELL IN
THE IN THE EXECUTIVE THE SHIP.
THAT I TOOK. WITH AJ I THINK
THERE WAS THE THERE WAS A
COMMON. THEME AND ATTITUDE
AROUND IT'S VERY SPECIFIC PARTS
OF PROMOTION AND LEADERSHIP
WHICH ARE. YOU KNOW AT THAT
LEADERSHIP PATH WHICH YOU KNOW
AROUND SALARY NEGOTIATION.
ASKING FOR WHAT YOU WANT.
HAVING TOP CONVERSE AS WITH YOU
KNOW YOUR BOSS OR YOUR MANAGER
UP OUT. GETTING WHAT YOU NEED
IN ORDER TO THRIVE. I THINK
HELLO THERE WAS A- BEEN FEELING
OF. OKAY HOW DO WE DO THIS WE
MAY BE HE- OR TO DO IT AND IT
MAKES AGAIN HER NAME. A LOT OF
THIS. THE CULTURAL AND ACTUALLY
TIE. BUT WORKS. GATHER CAN WE
PUT THIS SO MUCH OF ANYTHING WE
KNOW WE CAN. AND ROTH BY AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO THEN FEEL
MORE CONFIDENT WHEN PUT IN THAT
SITUATION THAT FEELS REALLY
COUNTER INTUITIVE. WE WERE
RAISED. AND MAYBE ONE FINAL
QUESTION OF. SO WHERE IN THE
PAN WAS IT YOU CAN TELL US
WHETHER WE'RE NEWSMAKERS OR NOT
GENERAL POLICY WE HAVE OTHER
PEOPLE ACTUALLY WE TED JUST
ENTERTAINING PANEL SOMETHING
PEOPLE LIKE COVER THAT YOU KNOW
THE NEWSMAKERS WE HAVE TECH
COMING UP YOU KNOW WE HAD A
JUDGE. IT JUDGE. RULINGS MADE
IS THERE A ROLE I MEAN IS THERE
A ROLE FOR TO HELP SUPPORT API
JOURNALISTS AS NEWSMAKERS
POTENTIAL NEWSMAKERS. YES I
MEAN SUPPORT YOUR LOCAL NEWS
ORGANIZATION. I DONATE BECOME A
MEMBER YEAH AND SOME THIS IS
ALSO JUST RAISING A PROFILES
AND SOME SOLIDARITY WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY RIGHT IT AND WE'RE IN
A LITTLE LAND SORT OF THE-
ONLINE I MEAN. BETH PERSONAL
BRANDS ARE IMPORTANT IN BEING
ABLE TO ACTUALLY EXPRESS THAT
PARTICULAR COVERAGE IS
IMPORTANT TO THE COMMUNITY. AND
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE CHASING
CLICKS AN AD DOLLARS SO SHOWING
UP ACTUALLY MATTERS. AND I
THINK YOU HAVE A PLATFORM TO
STRESS HOW IMPORTANT JOURNALISM
IS TO DEMOCRACY. AND TO
COUNTERACT MAYBE OTHER
NARRATIVES THAT ARE HAPPENING
AROUND JOURNALISM. THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU ALL CAN HELP
TO AMPLIFY AS FAR AS THE
IMPORTANCE OF KEEPING THIS
INDUSTRY. LIVE FOLKS CAN DO
ABOUT IT. AND HOW THEY CAN TO
PAY I THINK DODD A LOT OF. ARE
GETTING MORE AUDIENCE AND PICK
AN AUDIENCE FOCUSED. AND
GETTING PHONE REALLY
PARTICIPATE. OF THE JOURNALISM.
THANKS A LOT FOR OTHER
INDEPENDENT EVENTS. WELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MY
RESERVATION THANK YOU. HEY
SORRY NEXT PANEL. IS ON TECH
AND WE HAVE. I SEE WE HAVE SIX
WELL DEVELOPED ROAD SIDE SIXTY
FOUR HERE SO WE HAVE TO FALL
SOME MORE CHAIRS HERE WE HAVE
BUCK CHEEKS A. OKAY ALL RIGHT
OKAY OKAY ALL RIGHT. OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO AT SO LET ME JUST
INTRODUCE EVERYONE FIRST AND
THEN I UNDERSTAND THAT MR LAW
HAS TO LEAVE TIME WISE SO ALL
RIGHT SO WE SO BASICALLY
ALRIGHT SO OUR PANEL IS WE HAVE
**** CHEEKS AV ADVISER TO
ASCEND FOUNDATION RESEARCH
MISTER G. FOUNDED THE DANCE
LEADERSHIP PROGRAM FOR IN
AMERICA NEGATIVE THE STANFORD
THE SCHOOL THE ONLY PRO YOUR
BUSINESS SCHOOL. WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ASIAN AMERICAN
EXECUTIVE LEADER. EXTEND THE
ABOUT THE DEARTH OF ASIAN
AMERICAN EXECUTIVES INCLUDING
PIECES HARVARD BUSINESS REVIEW
DARK TIMES AND MORE WE ALSO
DENISE PACK. SHE IS EXECUTIVE
ADVISER TO ASSENT THE NIECE
FACILITATES LEADERSHIP
WORKSHOPS FOR MID LEVEL
MANAGERS AND BECAUSE DEVELOP
THE ELEVATE PROGRAM FOR EARLY
AND CREATE PROFESSIONAL. WE
HAVE THE I COULD TELL GARA THAT.
I THINK OUR LINDA IS THE
PRESENT CEO FOR LEADERSHIP
EDUCATION FOR ASIAN PACIFIC C.
CORPORATE LEAP WHERE SHE IS
RESPONSIBLE LEAP STRATEGIC
COLLABORATION SUSTAINABILITY
RELATIONSHIPS IN COLLABORATION
AND WE HAVE DOCTOR ALLISON
SCOTT WHOSE CHIEF RESEARCH
OFFICER FOR THE POOR CENTER
WHERE SHE LEADS A RESEARCH
AGENDA EXAMINE THE EQUITY AND
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION
PARTICIPATE RETENTION IN THE
TECHNOLOGY WORK FOR SOMEONE TO
REPRESENT A POPULATIONS. AND
INTERSECTION ALLERGY AND BURY
YOUR SPACING WOMEN OF COLOR AND
COMPUTING I WILL SERVE MARYLAND
NAGEL WHO C. O. WATERMARK C. E.
O. WATERMARK MARYLAND LEAD
STRATEGIC INITIATIVES DESIGNED
TO HELP WOMEN ENHANCE OUR
PERSONAL PROFESSIONAL IMPACT
ALLEN CONSULTS WITH PRE OPPOSE
I. BUT HE'S JIM FIVE HUNDRED
MULTI. NO COMPANIES DEVELOPING
AND IMPLEMENTING PURSE STRAP.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST AND HIS
GOING BECAUSE SPEAKING FIRST
THIS TEDDY LAUGH C. OF NEXT
RIGHT LEADER AND CONTACT CENTER
SOLUTIONS AN INNOVATOR IN THE
FOR IN THE- IN THE WORK FROM
HOME AGENT MODEL AND PRIOR TO
NEXT REP YOU MANAGE A TWENTY
THOUSAND VIRTUAL WORKFORCE
BUSINESS UNIT AT LIVE OPS. AND
FREE C. HELD ROLES AT LEVI
STRAUSS AND COMPANY CAN A
COMPUTER SYSTEMS AND TECH THE
CIVIC. SO WELCOME ALL OF YOU
AND I THINK WE'LL BEGIN WITH
SLOP GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH SO
WHAT WE'RE I KNOW WE'RE SHORT
ON TIME I'M GOING TO GO TO THE
AIRPORT FOR ANOTHER CONFERENCE
AND SPEAK THERE BUT- I WILL
KEEP MY PART AT LEAST. A SOURCE
BEN CAN CAN POSSIBLE SO WE'VE
GOT EIGHT AMERICANS REPRESENTED
BY POINT 6% AMERICA. RIGHT LIKE
THAT'S THAT WE ALL KNOW. AND.
SCENT OF THE AMERICAN WORKFORCE
WHITE COLLAR. WORKFORCE ASIA
MARKET SO WE ACTUALLY THIS IS
REALLY WE'RE DONE. IT'S OVER WE
WANT. RIGHT FIVE POINT SIX
POPULATION TWELVE PERCENT. OVER
OVER REPRESENTATION. AND WHITE
COLLAR WORKFORCE AND WORK
ABSOLUTELY NOT THAT'S NOT THE
STORY. BECAUSE EVEN BLOOMBERG
IN A STUDY THAT THEY DID SO
THAT. A WELL KNOWN COMPANY THE
J. BECAUSE OUR A GOLDMAN SACHS.
THE UP 27% OF THEIR WORKFORCE
THAT'S ASIAN AMERICAN BUT ONLY
11% OF SENIOR MANAGEMENT OR
ABOVE. IS ASIAN AMERICAN WHAT
ABOUT CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE GOT THIRTY FIVE PERCENT.
OF THE SITE THE BAY AREA'S
POSSIBLY 35% THE BAY IS ASIAN
AMERICAN. RIGHT BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT INDIVIDUAL CONTRIBUTORS
WE REPRESENT FORTY SEVEN
PERCENT. AND AT THE LEADERSHIP
LEVEL IT'S ONLY TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. SO THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
WORK TO BE DONE. AND WHILE BUT-
I DO NEED TO HAVE A PLETHORA OF
ADDITIONAL THAT'S TO. THE STORY
PAN PICTURE. WHAT I WANT TO
HUMANIZE IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
IN THE STORY. SO THERE WILL
COME IS A VERY LOW. COMPANY
WHAT. THE PAST. MY PRE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT. AND I ROSE UP YOU
KNOW SENIOR DIRECTOR AND I WAS
BUILDING CLIENT SERVICES ON HIS
BOOK. AND SERVICE DELIVERY IN
ALL THESE DIFFERENT BUSINESS
UNITS. AND ONE OF THE THINGS I
DID WAS I HAD TO AS I WAS
BUILDING HIRE PEOPLE. ONLY CAME
TO MY ATTENTION THAT I WAS
ACTUALLY FLY BY HR FOR MY HIGH
IMPACT IS. BECAUSE I WAS HIRING
TOO MANY ASIAN AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA. I WAS HAVING TOO
MANY ASIAN OUT. DIDN'T CARE
THAT. EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT
I HIRED IN OUR PHOENIX OFFICE
EVERY. EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM
WAS WHITE. A 100% OF MY HIRING
IN PHOENIX WAS WHITE. BUT THEN
I WAS FLAGGED FOR HIRING ASIAN
AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA THE BAY
AREA. I BUILD ANOTHER BUSINESS
UNIT IN THIS. AND AT EVERY
SINGLE PERSON THAT THAT WAS IN
THIS BUSINESS UNIT A 100% OF
THE PEOPLE WENT TO STANFORD. I
WAS A CAL VERY VERY PROUD OF
THAT THAT I BUILD. OKAY I GET
FLAGGED FOR HIRING PEOPLE THAT
ALL WENT TO STANFORD FOR
SPECIFIC NEW STEALTH TIGER TEAM
NO BUT I GOT FLAGGED FOR HIRING
ASIAN AMERICANS A CLIENT
SERVICES OUT OF A CALIFORNIA
OFFICE THAT IS CRAZY THAT IS
ABSURD AND THAT TYPE OF
INTIMIDATION AND HAVING TO LOOK
OVER MY SHOULDER AND HOW TO IN
AND HAVING TO IT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WOW IS DOES EVERYBODY HAVE
OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED OR A SORRY
ABOUT THIRTEEN. HUNDRED SAT
SCORE WITH. THIS UP IN ANYWAY
BUT WHICH WAY BUT WHAT THEY
CHOSE TO FOCUS ON WAS THAT. SO
I DECIDE TO LEAVE THE COMPANY.
AND IT BECAME C. OF THAT TRIP.
AND IN THE FIRST MONTH I
DECIDED THAT I WAS GONNA HAVE
EVERYBODY FROM ALL OF THE
COUNTRY COME INTO MIKE MY COME
DOWN THE C. E. O. EVERYBODY'S.
NOW THOSE WHO YEMEN I DON'T
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT I COULD
CLIMB UP THE RANKS I DON'T NEED
TO ACTUALLY I'M AT THE TOP OF
THE RINGS. SO THIS IS GREAT. SO
I ALLEN ALL HANDS MEETING AND I
HAD EVERYBODY FLY IN AND I HAD
MY HEAD OF ENGINEERING OREGON
PORTLAND OREGON WHO CAME AND-
ONLY HAD NEVER LOOK AT MY LINK
IN. AFTER MONTHS OKAY BECAUSE
HE'S NOT JOURNEY JUST DOING A
THING THAT'S FINE I RESPECT
THAT HE'S DOI. SO THE-
INTERACTION I. HAD WITH HIM WAS
THIS OKAY SO YOU'RE ME OKAY
SENATOR HANNAH. HE GOES UP TO
THE CO FOUNDER HEY JOHN HOW'S
IT GOING GIVE LOG. GOOD TO ME
HEY I'M- AND YOUR TEDDY AS SOON
AS HE SHOOK MY HAND. WHAT WHAT
WHAT DOES THE ROOM HE WALKED
OUT OF THE ROOM THE WHOLE THANK
YOU REALIZE THAT WAS AN ASIAN
IMMENSE ASIAN AMERICAN CEO OF
THE COMPANY. AND THAT TYPE OF
RACISM OVER FROM MY OWN
EMPLOYEES OF A COUPLE. OF IS
STILL OCCURRING TODAY SO MY
PLEA IS AND THERE'S A LOT OF
SOLUTIONS MY PLEA IS. WE GOT WE
GOT INVEST INTO DIVERSITY
INCLUSION PROGRAMS THIS IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING WE GOT A
LOOK AT HOLDING THE BIG
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE WE'VE GOT
A SUPPORT FINANCIALLY WITH THE
WITH COMPANIES THAT ARE MID
SIZE OR SMALL CANNELLA
COMPANIES THAT HAVE DIVERSITY
INCLUSION PROGRAMS AND HELP
FIND THOSE WE GOT A LOOK AT
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO BE A
MINORITY BUSINESS. GOING TO
SURVIVE COMPANY AND WE THANKS
TO SUPPORT THAT. FORTY MUST
LEAD THE A. BECAUSE THEY'VE NOT
CALIFORNIA WHAT'S HE'S GOING TO
MONTANA. ARIZONA IT'S GONNA BE
CALIFORNIA THAT LEAVES LEADS
THE WAY PAVE THE WAY FOR
LEADERSHIP IN IN THIS ARENA SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THIS IS A CAPSULE IMPORTANT. SO
THEY. A GREAT THANK YOU C. FIVE
YEAH. ALL RIGHT MY NAME IS
BUFFY AND I'M DODD WHAT DATA
JUDGE GO SORRY ONE A DAY THAT
WE WILL TALK WITH DATA AND I
JUST CAN GIVE A SAMPLE OF THE
RESEARCH THAT I SEND DOES IN
PARTICULAR WE TALK ABOUT THE
EVIL ONE AND WHAT IT THE DATA
CONTAINED AND WHAT WE CAN DO
ABOUT IT AND INSIGHTS. YOU CAN
COME OUT YOU COME OUT WITH. SO
JUST TO BEGIN TO HIS WORKS. FOR
THOSE HAVEN'T SEEN AT THIS WHAT
AN EO ONE WOULD LOOK. OR SERIES
REPORTS THAT EVERY COMPANY OVER
A HUNDRED. OVER HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES HAS TO FOLLOW THE EOC
EVERY YEAR. AND YOU'LL FOCUS
YOUR ATTENTION ON THE LEFT SIDE
OF THE CHART WHICH HAS
BASICALLY THE JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS AND FOCUS ON
TOP THREE LEVELS WHICH WERE THE
WHITE COLLAR JOBS. IS
EXECUTIVES MIDLEVEL MANAGERS
AND PROFESSIONALS PROFESSIONALS
ARE ESSENTIALLY THOSE JOBS
REQUIRE A COLLEGE EDUCATION.
ACROSS THE TOP. IS THE WORK
FORCE BROKEN DOWN BY RACE AND
GENDER. AND WHAT I WANT TO DO
IS FOCUS ON ONE COLUMN FOR
EXAMPLE LOOKING AT ASIAN WOMEN.
AND THE NUMBER THERE BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT PERCENTAGES THAT I'VE
CALCULATED HERE HE SEES IT AS
YOU GO TO THE PIPELINE ASIAN
WOMEN NUMBERS DECLINED HERS
REPRESENTATION. WE ALL KNOW
THAT AND THE AND SO THE DATE IS
NICE BUT THAT BETTER BETTER
THING YOU DO THE DATA IS STILL
CALCULATION. AND LOOK AT THE
FALLOUT. THROUGH THE PIPELINE.
SO WE CREATED THERE'S TWO TO
TWO TERMS OKAY WANT US TO LOOK
AT THE FALLOUT FROM
PROFESSIONAL WHICH IS INTEREST
CONTRIBUTOR. TO EXECUTIVE LEVEL
FOLKS WHO EXECUTIVE PARITY. AND
IF YOU LOOK AT A POINT TWO
SEVEN TWO TWO ONE SEVEN DODD
APPOINT A NINE POINT. TEN POINT
NINETY IS. POINT TWENTY FIVE.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS PERCENTAGE
AT THE TOP. IS ONLY 25% AT THE
CENTER OF THE BOTTOM THE IWIN
TRIP THAT IS SENTRY ASIAN
WOMEN. ARE 75% BELOW PARITY IN
TERMS OF THEIR THEIR THEIR
THEIR REPRESENTATION WORKFORCE.
CHEVROLET YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
MANAGER PARITY YOU SEE THAT
ASIAN WOMEN POINT FOUR FOUR
MEANS THERE FIFTY SIX PERCENT.
HELLO FORTY OR FIFTY CENT FIFTY
SIX PERCENT. BOCA BATES SAID G.
UNDER REPRESENTED IT'LL MANAGER.
CASE OF YOU UNDERSTAND THAT AS
A BASIC CONCEPT. AND THE NICE
THING ABOUT THIS IS THAT THEN I
CAN DO NORMAL IS NORMALIZED
COMPARISONS BETWEEN ALL COURTS.
SO IN THIS EXAMPLE YOU CAN SEE
EXACTLY HOW EACH COHORT OF
GENDER AND RACE FARE AGAINST
EACH OTHER. AND ONE CAVEAT HERE
IS THE NUMBERS FOR BLACK
HISPANIC ARE SO LOW. THE F. B.
CAREFUL THAT THE NUMBERS ARE
OUR LOAN OF THEIR DID THERE'S
NOT A SIGNIFICANT. THE MORE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS ARE FOR IT
ASIAN MEN ASIAN WOMEN COMPARED
TO WHITE MEN OR WHITE WOMEN AND
YOU SEE HOW ASIAN BAND A FULL
AND FAIR IN THIS EXAMPLE. SO
THE POWER OF THE D. L. ONE IS
CLEARLY DEMONSTRATES. HOUSES
SHOWS YOU EXACTLY WHAT THE GAPS
ARE BETWEEN ASIAN AND WHITE
PRINCIPALLY OKAY. SO YOU CAN
SEE THAT FOR EXAMPLE THAT ASIAN
WOMEN. BEGAN ARE THE LEAST
REPRESENTED. RHONDA RELATIVE
BASIS FOR EXAMPLE IN MIDDLE
MANAGEMENT. THAT THAT THAT
ASIAN MEN BASICALLY OUR PROPER
MESSAGING PROMOTED THIS COMPANY
AT LOWER RATES AND- AGAIN FOR
THIS IS TRUE. AGAINST ALL BOOK
UP BLACK HISPANIC. OKAY THE
NICE THING ABOUT THIS THEN WHAT
YOU UNDERSTAND THE COMPARE. IS
IF YOU HAVE THE DATA ACROSS
COMPANIES AND YOU AND WE HAVE A
EOC DATA FOR NINETEEN DIFFERENT
COMPANIES IN SILICON VALLEY.
YOU CAN COMPARE WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE IN DIFFERENT COMPANIES.
THESE ARE THE NINETEEN
COMPANIES THAT ARE THAT MAKE
THEIR APPEAL IS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE AND THE TWO THINGS I
WANT TO POINT OUT IN THIS SLIDE.
THERE ARE BETTER ELEMENT FIRST
IS THAT IN YOU CAN SEE IN
ALMOST ALL THIS IS THE TOP ONE
IS. MANAGER PARITY FOR. FOR
MEN. AT WHITE AND ASIAN AND THE
BOTTOM IS A MAJOR PRIORITY FOR
WOMEN WHITE AND ASIAN AND WHAT
YOU SEE IS THAT. ALMOST ALL
COMPANIES IN SILICON VALLEY
SAMPLE. THAT WHITE MEN AND
WHITE WOMEN ARE ABOVE PARITY IN
MIDDLE MANAGEMENT. ALL
COMPANIES IN SILICON VALLEY
SAMPLE ALL ASIAN MEN AND ASIAN
WOMEN ARE BELOW PARITY IN
MIDDLE MANAGEMENT UNDER
REPRESENT MIDDLE MANAGERS. IN
THE END AND THERE AVERAGE HERE
THE OTHER SILICON VALLEY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN IT'S REALLY THAT
THE NUMBERS THAT WERE ACTUALLY
PUT TOGETHER A BY THE BUT YOU
RECEIVE HAMPSHIRE ON A PROJECT
THEY DID THEY DID FOR THE
CENTER OF INVESTING REPORTING
AND REVEAL THAT LOOKED AT THE
ACCURATE NUMBERS SO HOLLY. AND
THAT AVERAGE SO WAS ESSENTIALLY
BUT A WHITE MAN OR WHITE WOMAN.
SUCH HAS A DOUBLE THE UP DOUBLE
THE CHANCE OF BEING PROMOTED.
AMANDA RACHEL SO THIS IS THE
VALUE OF THE DATA AND ANALYSIS
OF POINT OKAY I'M YOU CAN FIND
AGGREGATED DATA AT THE EEOC NOT
INDIVIDUAL AGGREGATED DATA AT
THE IT IT BUT YOU'LL SEE
WEBSITE AND IT'S EVERY YEAR BY
NET FIND NATIONAL DATA. STATE
AND LOCAL DATA. AND WITHIN
THOSE AGGREGATIONS YOU CAN FIND
IT BY SECTOR. SO FOR EXAMPLE I
CAN LOOK AT CALIFORNIA. AND
HERE'S THE NUMBERS FOR EXAMPLE
ALL INDUSTRIES IN EACH MATCH
BALL THE LARGE METROPOLITAN
AREAS IN CALIFORNIA. AND A
COMPUTER EXACTLY PARITY INDEX
FOR EACH OF THESE. AND THE
THING THAT NOTE IS THAT BY AND
LARGE TO SHAPE THE CURVE IS
CENTRAL ST. THAT ASIAN MAN AN
ASIAN WOMEN ARE FARING LESS
WELL THAN WHITE MEN AND WHITE
WOMEN. IT SAYS AGAIN IF YOU
LOOK AT SUCCESS IS THE GENDER
GAP. BUT THE UPSHOT OF THIS
CHART SHOULD BE THIS. IF YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE GLASS CEILING YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION OF RACE AND
GENDER AND IN EFFECT AND THE
EFFECT OF THE INTERSECTION OF
BOTH. THAT'S WHAT THIS SHOWS.
SO IN SUMMARY I WANT TO SUM UP
CENTRAL WHAT WE FOUND. WITH OUR
RESEARCH USING IO ONES. NUMBER
ONE. THAT AT LEAST THE DATA IS
THE DATA IS AND WE FOCUS ON
SILICON VALLEY FOR BECAUSE
WE'RE HERE. WE FOUND BASICALLY
THAT THAT ASIAN AND ASIAN WOMEN
ARE THE LEAST LIKELY BE
PROMOTED. SO FOUND BY THE WAY
THAT LOOKED AT DATA NOT JUST
FOR ASIANS BUT FOR BLACK
HISPANICS WE ALSO SEE IS ALL
THE NUMBERS OF. OF BLACKS
HISPANICS HAVE INCREASED I
SHOULD RATHER THAN PATIENT
DECREASED SO AS A REGION WE'RE
NOT DOING WELL SO THAT'S OTHER
OTHER VALUE OF THE DATA SO YOU
CAN LOOK. AT EVERYBODY'S
REPORTS IN CONTEXT OF WHAT'S
GOING ON OKAY SO THE DATA IS
THERE. IT'S ONLY THE POWER FOR
THE COMPANIES THAT ARE WILLING
SCHOOL. AS TO THE CENTER FOR
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING. I
ACTUALLY WANTED TO GET. FILED A
FEED RESERVATION REQUESTS TO A
LOT OF COMPANIES AND WE'RE DONE
DIED THEY SUED THEM. AND GOT A
REPORTS FROM BUT I THINK TEN
OTHERS. SO A LOT OF PEOPLE
UNWILLING TO RELEASE REPORTS.
THAT LIMITS WHAT WE CAN DO IN A
COMPARISON VALLEY AND THE
NUMBERS IN SOME VALUE ALL THOSE
AVAILABLE THEY'RE NOT
AVAILABLE. OUTSIDE I HAVEN'T
SEEN ANY REPEAL ONE FROM
REPORTER BY ANY OTHER COMPANY
OUTSIDE SO VALLEY. AND IF WE
COULD WE COULD DO WORK WITH AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING ON
HOLLY WOULD WE COULD FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON LAW FIRMS. BUT
THAT'S NOT THERE. SO A LOT OF
WORK TO BE DONE. THANK YOU. UP
FIRST OF ALL NORMALLY I AM AN
EXECUTIVE VISOR TO ASCEND BUT
TODAY I AM HERE TO PRESENT A
STATEMENT FROM MR JEFF CHIN WHO
IS PRESIDENT OF A SENT THE
LARGEST PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATION WITH A MISSION TO
EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND ENABLE PAN
ASIAN BUSINESS LEADERS TO REACH
EXECUTIVE LEVELS AND THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS. FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON API FARES AND THE
CALIFORNIA API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS FOR HOLDING THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME I'M AWARE OF
FOUR STATE LEGISLATORS ARE
HOLDING A PUBLIC HEARING TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC OF THE A. P. I.
CLASS CEILING. ASIAN AMERICAN
BOTH IMMIGRANT AN AMERICAN
BORN. HAVE BECOME A VITAL FORCE
IN THE GROWTH AND VITALITY IN
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS CULTURAL
AND CIVIC LANDSCAPE. WE'RE NOW
14% OF THE STATE POPULATION 33%
OF HIS WHITE COLLAR WORKFORCE.
AS THE MAJORITY OF SILICON
VALLEY'S HIGH TECH WORK FORCE
ASIAN AMERICANS ARE PROUD TO BE
THE ENGINE THAT POWERS THE
REGION'S INNOVATION AND ENERGY.
BUT AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM OTHERS
A OUR CHIEF MEN'S HAVE OBSCURED
THE COMMUNITY'S FRUSTRATION IN
REACHING MORE LEADERSHIP ROLES
ACROSS SOCIETY FROM LAW TO
JOURNALISM FROM ENTERTAINMENT
TO TECHNOLOGY SECTORS. ASCENDS
OWN RESEARCH WHICH BUCK JUST
TALKED ABOUT. USING AVAILABLE
EOC DATA DEMONSTRATES THAT IN
SPITE OF HI EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT LEVELS ASIAN
AMERICANS ARE THE LEAST LIKELY
TO BE PROMOTED TO MANAGEMENT.
AND ALTHOUGH MANY POINT TO
SINGULAR EXAMPLES OF ASIAN
AMERICAN C. E. O.'S STEM
SYSTEMATIC ANALYSIS SHOWS WE
HAD THE LEAST LIKELY TO REACH
EXECUTIVE LEVEL CALIFORNIA. THE
SAME EOC DATA ALSO ALLOWS US TO
QUANTIFY MARGINAL PROGRESS FOR
BLACKS AND HISPANIC POPULATION
IN THE WORK FORCE AS WELL. WE
KNOW THIS BECAUSE WHAT POOR
DATA IS AVAILABLE FORM A
FEDERALLY MANDATED DATED E. E.
O. ONE REPORTS REQUIRING RACE
AND GENDER DETAILS BY JOB
CATEGORIES. ALTHOUGH
CONFIDENTIALLY SUBMITTED TO THE
EEOC MANY LEADING COMPANIES ARE
NOW MAKING THEIR EO ONE REPORTS
AVAILABLE ON THEIR WEBSITES
INCLUDING THE COMPANIES THAT
USE ON BUCKS LIGHTS APPLE
FACEBOOK GOOGLE AND SALES
FORCE. HOWEVER 90% OF THE
COMPANIES IN SILICON VALLEY DO
NOT PUBLICLY DISCLOSE ITS DATA.
A SON WAS FOUNDED IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE WITH A FOCUS TO
HELP ASIAN AMERICANS REACH
THEIR FULL POTENTIAL AND TO
ADVANCE. THROUGH RESEARCH
LEADERSHIP TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT AND NETWORKING
ACTIVITIES THAT TARGET THE FULL
CAREER SPECTRUM FROM COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO MANAGEMENT TO
EXECUTIVES AND BOARD DIRECTORS.
IN ADDITION TO THE SAMPLE OF
THE ANALYTICAL RESEARCH
PRESENTED TODAY WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A NATIONAL NETWORK
OF ASIAN AMERICAN CORPORATE
BOARD DIRECTORS AND EXECUTIVES
I WORK WITH FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED COMPANIES TO MENTOR AND
DEVELOP LEADERS. THIS EFFORT
ALSO INCLUDES AN ELEVEN YEAR
LONG COLLABORATION WITH
STANFORD GRADUATE SCHOOL
BUSINESS ON AN EXECUTIVE
EDUCATION PROGRAM FOR ASIAN FOR
SENIOR. WE ARE IN PROGRESS BUT
ASK FOR YOUR HELP HELP TACKLE
ONE OF THE MOST CHALLENGING
ASPECTS WE HAVE SEEN WITH THE
API GLASS CEILING WHICH IS THE
LACK OF URGENCY AND AWARENESS
IN THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS. IN YOUR ROLE AS THE
VISIBLE AN INFLUENTIAL API
LEADERS IN CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW
THAT YOUR WORDS AND ACTIONS
WILL SPUR HIGHER LEVELS OF
ENGAGEMENT OR CORPORATE LEADERS.
FIRST WE ASK THAT COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA FINALLY E. O. ONE
READ PORTS WITH THE EEOC WITH
THE EEOC SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO
MAKE THOSE REPORTS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE. THE EO ONE REPORT IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE A PROVIDE DATA
IN INSIGHTS INTO DEMOGRAPHIC
REPRESENTATION BY GENDER RACE
AND JOB CATEGORIES AND CAN HELP
IDENTIFY REPRESENTATION. AND
ADVANCEMENT ISSUES FOR EACH
IDENTIFY COHORT AGAIN BY GENDER
RACE IN ORGANIZATIONAL LEVELS.
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE WITH
FACILITATE COMPARISONS ACROSS
COMPANIES AND INDUSTRIES OVER
TIME. WE OFFER A LETTER WHICH
IS AND YOUR ORANGE PACKET
SUPPORTING THIS POSITION THIS
LETTER IS COSIGNED BY THE MONTE
J. TO WEST SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION. ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER PUBLIC AFFAIRS
INDIA'S BORA AND THE ASIAN
PACIFIC AMERICAN LEADERSHIP
INSTITUTE. IN ADDITION WE ASK
FOR YOUR HELP IN ORGANIZING A
STATEWIDE SUMMIT ON THE API
GLASS CEILING TO EXPAND THE
DISCUSSION IN THIS HEARING A
SUMMIT TO ENGAGE MAJOR C. E.
O.'S WITH API LEADERS AND
FINALLY FOCUS THE DIVERSITY
SPOTLIGHT. ON THE NEGLECTED
PROBLEM OF THE ASIAN API
COMMUNITY. A SON WOULD BE HAPPY
TO HELP YOU IN LEADING THAT
EFFORT. THESE MEASURES ARE JUST
THE FIRST STEP SENATE DRESSING
THE API CLASS CEILING. WE HAVE
NO ILLUSIONS THAT THERE IS A
QUICK FIX AS THE MULTI DECADE
STRUGGLE FOR GENDER EQUALITY
HAS DEMONSTRATED. NEVER THE
LESS WE BELIEVE THAT SUCH
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE WILL
ENCOURAGE ALL COMPANIES TO MORE
CLOSELY EXAMINE THE PROGRESS
MADE BY THEIR DIVERSITY
PROGRAM. IT WOULD HASTEN
PROGRESS TO A FAIR AND MORE
EQUITABLE WORKPLACE. WE ASSERT
THAT INCREASE TRANSPARENCY IS
NOT IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST
THROUGH THE RELEASE OF THE
CONFIDENTIAL E. O. ONE REPORTS.
WE HOPE THAT YOU AGREE WITH THE
NEED FOR TRANSPARENCY AND WOULD
CONSIDER A PROPOSAL FOR ALL
COMPANIES DOING BUSINESS IN THE
STATE. TO MAKE THEIR E. OLD ONE
REPORTS PUBLIC. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY.
THANK YOU. AND HE SAID JOHN FOR
BEING IN THIS MEETING. OKAY
THERE WE GO YES ALL RIGHT SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CONVENING THIS MEETING AND THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING MY NAME
IS LINDA COUP TO COLIN I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO FELIPE
LEADERSHIP EDUCATION FOR ASIAN
PACIFICS WE ARE NOW A NEARLY
FORTY YEAR OLD ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON GROWING AND
DEVELOPING AND ON CAPULET OR
FROM WITHIN THE ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE ARE BASED
IN LOS ANGELES AND ACTUALLY
SENATOR CHOW YOU'RE MY DAD'S
DISTRICTS SO YOU'RE HIS SENATOR.
I THOUGHT I JUST MENTION THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING AS LOW
ALONG WITH MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS TO RAISE THE
PROFILE OF ASIAN AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS INTO
LEADERSHIP ROLES WE BELIEVE
THAT TO BE ABLE TO IN. A SICKLY
ENACT CHANGE WHAT WE NEED TO DO
IS WE NEED OUR PRESENCE OUT
THESE TABLES WHERE DECISIONS
ARE BEING MADE NOT ONLY JUST
PRESENCE BUT ALSO HAVING OUR
VOICES HEARD. I'M ALSO HERE AS
THE CHAIR OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
DIVERSITY WHICH IS A COALITION
OR PARTNERSHIP OF FOR
LEADERSHIP ORGANIZATIONS
CATALYST WHICH IS A GLOBAL
WOMEN'S ORGANIZATION OUR E. L.
C. WHICH IS THE EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL THEY OR THE
ALL FOR MOST ORGANIZATION FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS. HI SIR WHICH
IS THE HISPANIC ASSOCIATION FOR
CORPORATE RESPONSIBILITY WHICH
IS A COALITION OF TWELVE
DIFFERENT NATIONAL HISPANIC
ORGANIZATIONS AND OF COURSE
LEAVE AND OUR FOCUS IS PATRICIA
LEE ON ADVOCATING FOR GREATER
DIVERSITY ON CORPORATE BOARDS
WHAT I'M BRINGING TODAY HERE IS
A PERSPECTIVE ON THE NEED FOR
GREATER DIVERSITY IN
REPRESENTATIONAL CORPORATE
BOARDS. AND ALSO TALK A BIT
ABOUT ON. WHAT. THEY SCHIRMER
CANS ARE ARE GOING TO BE NEEDED
IN THESE PLACES. MENTIONING AB
D. BECAUSE WE'RE BEST KNOWN FOR
OUR MISSING PIECES REPORT THE
BOARD DIVERSITY SENSES OF WOMEN
AND MINORITIES ON FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED CORPORATE BOARDS WHICH
WE'VE BEEN PRODUCING SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. AND I BELIEVE
THAT I BILL I REALLY BELIEVE IN
THE SCENE. WHAT GETS MEASURED
GETS DONE. AND LIKE THE A
SENATE REPORT THAT WAS AUTHORED
BY BUCK G. ANTONY'S PACK THE
MISSING PIECES REPORT IS MEANT
TO SHINE A SPOTLIGHT. ON FAX
AND THE FACT BASED REALITY
ABOARD SENSES NUMBER AND IN THE
PROCESS SPUR GREATER AWARENESS
AN OPTION FOR INCREASED
INCLUSION OF DIVERSE DIRECTORS
ON CORPORATE BOARDS. WHAT MORE
SPECIALLY I BELIEVE THAT USING
DATA THAT WE PRODUCE FOR
REPORTS LIKE THIS ALSO DEBUNKS
THE MISPERCEPTIONS ABOUT THE
OVER REPRESENTATION OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ON CORPORATE BOARDS.
UNFORTUNATELY EVEN IN SPACES
THAT YOU WOULD THINK PEOPLE NO.
DON'T ALWAYS REALLY UNDERSTAND
THE TRUE NUMBERS AND OFTEN
TIMES A STUDENT THAT ASIANS ARE
MUCH BETTER REPRESENTED THEN
WHEN WE REALLY ARE AND I WILL
SAY THAT IT'S BEEN TO MY SHOCK
FORTUNATELY AND I'M NO LONGER
SHOCKED. THAT IN THE DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION SPACE WHO I FEEL
SHOULD KNOW BETTER DON'T OFTEN
KNOW BETTER AND THEY'RE OFTEN
TIMES WHEN TWEET THE SAME IT
ASSISTS ANYONE ELSE'S. WE'LL
SHARE THAT IN THE NUMBERS THAT
ARE GONNA SPEAK ABOUT THERE ARE
INDICATORS FOR OPTIMISM FOR
THIS COMMUNITY OUR COMMUNITY
THE ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
BUT I WILL SAY THAT ADVANCEMENT
IS SLOW AND CORPORATE BOARDS
ARE NOT STILL REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE BROAD DEMOGRAPHIC
TRANSFORMATIONS THAT WE'VE SEEN
IN THIS COUNTRY. QUEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
SAW THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
AVAILABLE CORPORATE BOARD SEATS
GROW LARGER BY ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY SEATS SO IN AN
ANALOGY I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THE PIE HAS GROWN SLIGHTLY
LARGER. AND INSTEAD OF JUST
GETTING A SLIVER NOW WE GET
MORE OF A SLICE IN TERMS OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES. BUT WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS THAT GROWTH IS
BEING LED BY FORTUNE ONE
HUNDRED COMPANIES. AND YET
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS ARE
SPECIFICALLY I'LL JUST SAY THIS
ASIAN AMERICANS GREW FASTEST IN
TERMS OF BOARD SEATS ON THE
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES
LIST. AGAIN AS I MENTIONED
UNDER REPRESENTATION STILL
ISSUE BUT HERE ARE SOME CONTEXT
FOR SMALL WHAT I'M GONNA SHARE
ON FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED BOARDS.
EIGHT TEN AMERICAN WOMAN LET
THE GAME. GROWTH RATE OF THIRTY
EIGHT POINT 6% SUCH A PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE RIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
POINT SIX PERCENT. IT'S ONLY
SEVENTEEN SEATS. ON THE FORTUNE
ONE HUNDRED ASIAN AMERICAN
WOMEN GAINED THIRTY POINT 8% IN
TERMS OF TOTAL BOARD SEATS
GROWN. IT WAS ONLY FOUR SEATS.
SO WHAT ARE WHY I'M SAYING THIS
IS THAT THE PERCENTAGES SAY ONE
THING BUT THE ACTUAL WRONG
NUMBER SAY SOMETHING ELSE AND
OUR NUMBERS AS ASIAN AMERICANS
WHEN OUR NUMBERS ARE SO LOW TO
BEGIN WITH ANY GROWTH IS GOING
TO SEEM LIKE WOW A LOT OF
GROWTH BUT IN TERMS OF THE
ACTUAL RUN NUMBERS IT'S REALLY
NOT THAT IMPRESSIVE. I WANT TO
JUST ALSO MENTION IN TERMS OF
SOME OF THE DATA THAT WE SHOW
IN OUR REPORT IS THE RECYCLE
RATE SO HOW OFTEN ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PUT ON TWO
BOARDS QUALICORP RECYCLED SO
USED TO SIT ON MALTA BOARD
SEATS AND OF COURSE MINORITY
BOARD SEATS OFTEN TIMES ARE. AT
A HIGHER RATE BUT INTERESTINGLY
RIGHT NOW EIGHT AMERICANS OF
THE LOS RECYCLE RATES ON BOTH
THE FORTUNE ONE HUNDRED FORTUNE
FIVE HUNDRED BOARDS BUT AND
WE'RE STILL. I ALSO WANT TO
JUST TWO ONE THING AND THE DATE
AROUND BOARDS THIRTY FIVE
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED PLEASE
TWENTY EIGHT CAD LEÓN ONE
DIRECTOR THAT WAS. EATEN
AFRICAN AMERICAN HISPANIC.
DEMOGRAPHIC FACTORS HOWEVER I
WANT TO MENTION THAT. FOR THE
TECH AND ENTERTAINMENT SECTORS
IF WE LOOK AT THE THIRTY FIVE
COMPANIES THERE ONLY TO TECH
COMPANIES THAT HAD BROAD
DIVERSITY. H. P. N. H. P.
ENTERPRISES. AND THERE ARE ONLY
TWO ENTERTAINMENT COMPANIES
THAT HAVE THE BROADEST
DIVERSITIES COMCAST
NBCUNIVERSAL AND WALT DISNEY.
THAT WAS IT NOT SURPRISING
GIVEN THE DATA THAT WE'VE SEEN
NO LAW FIRMS NO NO NEWSPAPERS
NO BIG SURPRISE RIGHT. SO I
THOUGHT I JUST MENTIONED THAT
THAT THERE'S SOME BUT THERE'S A
LOT MORE WORK TO BE DONE I
LASTLY I WANT TO JUST MENTION
IN TERMS OF THE CORPORATE BOARD
REPORT I JUST WANT TO MENTION
THAT FOR THE SAKE OF OUR- THE
USE OF THE WORDS ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS. I WANT TO
JUST NOTE THAT THERE IS A
COMPLETE ABSENCE OF NATIVE
HAWAIIANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
ON CORPORATE BOARDS AND SO FOR
THE RECORD I WANTED TO JUST
STATE THAT BECAUSE I THINK
OFTEN TIMES. I THINK FROM AN
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
PERSPECTIVE WE'RE FIGHTING FOR
RECOGNITION I THINK TOO OFTEN
WERE IN SPACES WERE WERE
COMPLETELY ERASED AND
OVERLOOKED. AND I THINK THE
SAME OUR IS BEING DONE TO
NATIVE HAWAIIANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS. I DO WANT TO JUST
SAY THAT DIVERSITY DOES WORK
AND IT MATTERS BUT I THINK. IT
TAKES SUPPORTERS. POLICY MAKERS
LIKE YOU ADVOCATES LIKE ALL OF
US HERE. TO STAY AWARE AND TO
ENSURE THAT WE DON'T GET
COMPLACENT AND THAT. WITH THE
DATA THAT WE GAIN WE GET A
BETTER LEYVA LOUD BUT THERE'S
ACTIONS THAT CAN AND SHOULD BE
TAKEN. SO FROM A POLICYMAKER
PERSPECTIVE I WILL RECOMMEND
THE STEPS ONE. I APPRECIATE AND
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE RAISING THESE ISSUES.
I THINK IN ABLE TO EDUCATE
PEOPLE MORE BROADLY IT'S GONNA
BE IMPORTANT BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S CONTINUE. TO BE. S.
MISPERCEPTION ABOUT OUR OVER
REPRESENTATION. I THINK
CONTINUING TO ASK. THE
QUESTIONS WHETHER IT'S M. PRIDE
OR ISN'T. ALL THE COMPANIES
DOING BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA IS
IMPORTANT AS WELL TOO BECAUSE
WHAT IT LIKE WHAT WE SHARED BY
THE HONORABLE JUDGE WHEN WE ASK
THESE QUESTIONS. PEOPLE START
TO TAKE NOTICE NOT ONLY FROM A
FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE BUT
BECAUSE YOU'RE ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CHALLENGE
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM BECAUSE I
THINK UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S A
LOT OF THAT AS WE HEARD FROM.
OUR FRIENDS IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT AND JOURNALISM
SECTORS I ALSO WANT TO MENTION
THAT IN IN TERMS OF THESE KIND
OF AREAS I THINK THERE'S ALSO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU TO WORK
WITH OUR CONGRESSIONAL. CATION
CONTINUE. URGED THEM TO ALSO
ASK QUESTIONS AND RAISE THE
ISSUES BECAUSE I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
THE HOUSE FINANCIAL SERVICES
COMMITTEE IN JUNE AND LET ME
TELL YOU. QUESTIONS WERE BEING
ASKED ABOUT EVERY SINGLE
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP EXCEPT FOR US.
JUST BY THE FACT THAT I WAS
THERE I FELT THAT AT LEAST THEN
WE HAD SOME ATTENTION BUT CAN
YOU IMAGINE IF I WASN'T THERE
THERE WAS NOT ONE ASIAN
AMERICAN OR PACIFIC ISLANDER
MEMBER ON THAT HOUSE FINANCIAL
SERVICES COMMITTEE. ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR COMMUNITIES
THEY WERE ASKING ABOUT
EVERYBODY ELSE BUT WE WERE
COMPLETELY INVISIBLE AND A
RAISED AGAIN. I WANT TO ALSO
SAY THAT FROM A COMPANY'S
PERSPECTIVE AND I KNOW WE HAVE
SOME COMPANIES IN HERE BUT I
ALSO WANT ENCOURAGE THIS AS
FOOD FOR THOUGHT FOR. FOR US
THE POLICY MAKERS I THINK WE
ASKING OR PLEASE WHAT ARE THEY
GOING TO ENCOURAGE THEIR
LEADERS TO SEEK OUT ASIAN
AMERICA AT AND PLEASE. BECAUSE
I THINK A LOT OF ASIAN
AMERICANS NO THAT'S SAUCE DON'T
KNOW WELL THE WRITTEN RULES BUT
SOMETIMES WE NEED SOMEBODY TO
REACH OUT TO US I KNOW WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO THE SAME AND
OFTEN TIMES WE ARE BUT WE MAY
NOT BE DOING IT IN THE RIGHT
WAY. WE MAY GIVE UP TOO EASILY
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GETTING THE
KIND OF ENCOURAGEMENT THAT WE
NEED I THINK WE SHOULD ALSO BE
ASKING COMPANIES ARE YOU URGING
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER TEAM
TO SCALP. YEAH TO HELP POUND TO
REGION AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS IN
THERE COME. ARE THEY DOING THAT
BECAUSE. I CAN TELL YOU A LOT
OF ASIAN AMERICANS. BEEN KNOW
WHAT'S. BEFORE AND I WILL SAY
THAT THIS IS A LITTLE BIT SELF.
SELF SERVING ON MY PART BUT AS
A WHAT I'LL CALL A LEADERSHIP
AGNOSTIC ORGANIZATIONS WE WORK
FROM THE CLASSROOM TO THE BOARD
ROOM ACROSS MULTIPLE SECTORS IN
LIFE STAGES. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE AND SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
BECAUSE A LOT OF OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS DON'T REALIZE WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO I THINK THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF ANGST IN TERMS OF
BEING. BEING ABLE TO HONOR OUR
CULTURAL HERITAGE. AND ALSO NOT
BE THE STEREO TYPE AND BEING
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE THAT IS
IMPORTANT AND IT'S- HELPFUL
WHEN WE COULD DO IT WITH THE
HELP OF OTHERS WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH THAT SAME ROAD. AND
THEN LASTLY I THINK THE ROONEY
RULE AND I THINK THAT'S BEEN
MENTIONED YOU KNOW USING THAT
AS A AS A REQUIREMENT TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS GREATER
DIVERSITY. SO BUT THAT. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON HI MY NAME IS
ALLISON SCOTT AND I AND THE
CHIEF RESEARCH OFFICER THE
KEEPER CENTER WERE BASED IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND THE
KEEPER CENTERS FOCUSED ON
INCREASING DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION ACROSS THE TECHNOLOGY
GO SYSTEM FROM K. TWELVE
EDUCATION THROUGH THE TECH WORK
FORCE AND INTO ENTREPRENEURSHIP
IN VENTURE CAPITAL SO THANK YOU
FOR THE INVITATION TO BE HERE
TODAY TO MAKE A FEW REMARKS SO
OUR RESEARCH AT THE KEEPER
CENTER EXAMINES LANDSCAPE DATA
AND BARRIERS FACING DIVERSE
GROUP SPECIFICALLY UNDER
REPRESENTED. PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND WOMEN ACROSS THE TECH
ECOSYSTEM AND SO WHAT MY
COMMENTS TODAY ARE GOING TO
CENTER AROUND THE WHAT WE FOUND
IN IN SOME OF THE LANDSCAPE
DATA WHICH IS THAT THE PICTURE
FOR ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER INTACT IS BOTH COMPLEX
SOME OF THE DATA THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN REVEALED I'M IN IN WAYS
IT'S COMPLETE AS WE HAVE A LACK
OF DISAGGREGATED DATA IN
TRANSPARENCY OF DATA ON
SPECIFIC SUBGROUPS AND THAT
REALLY I THINK CAMPERS. OUR
ABILITY TO UNDERSTAND SOME OF
THE TRENDS AND TO MAKE AND THIS
ONE'S ABOUT INTERVENTIONS SO
JUST TO START OFF IN CASE OF
EDUCATION YOU MIGHT THE ASIANS
DO OVER OPEN IN COMPUTERS THE
DUCATION. BUT NOT THE FULL
STORY. THE FACT I DID THE WE
NOW HAVE DIFFERENT. THE
VIETNAMESE STUDENTS ARE SIMONE
STUDENTS VERSUS CHINESE AND
KOREAN STUDENTS WE ALSO FOUND
THAT LOW INCOME STUDENTS ARE
ARE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS LIKELY
TO HAVE ACCESS TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION AND THEN OF
THE ASIAN STUDENTS WHO ARE
TAKING COMPUTER SCIENCE 70% ARE
MALE SO GOING BACK TO BUCKS
POINT THERE IS. WE MUST PAY
ATTENTION TO BOTH INTERSECTION
OF REASONS UNDER I'M IN THE
TECH WORK FORCE JUST TO
REITERATE WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN
SAID THANKS TO THE GROUND
BREAKING RESEARCH BY ASCENDS
FOUNDATION AND ALSO US AND DO
JEFF RING CARED JAN AT REVEAL
NEWS. WE KNOW THAT THE
ADVANCEMENT OF ASIAN AMERICANS
IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IN TECH
IN SILICON VALLEY ASIAN ASIANS
MAKE UP ABOUT 30% OF ALL TECH
EMPLOYEES BUT THE
REPRESENTATION DECREASES
SIGNIFICANTLY OUT THAT BOTH THE
MANAGERIAL AND EXECUTIVE LEVEL
WHICH WE JUST SAW FROM EO ONE.
A REPORT EXAMPLE I'M AND AGAIN
DATA OR WORK FOR ASIAN WOMEN
AND ASIAN WOMEN ACTUALLY C. N.
N. OUT COMPLETELY OPPOSITE
TREND FROM WHITE WOMEN SO I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE
TO POINT OUT. AS WE HEAR A LOT
OF TALK ABOUT OUR DIVERSITY IN
TECH. WE ALSO A STUDY IN THE
SIXTEEN REVERSED. WHICH BUT
INCLUDE WITH AN- S. AN OVERT
BIAS RIPPING. OFF MAN THIRD
TYPING TO BEING PASSED OVER FOR
PROMOTION WERE EXPERIENCES THAT
FOLKS WHO WENT THERE IN THE
DOOR IN TECH COMPANIES. WERE
THAN DRIVING THEM OUT SO I
THINK THAT ANOTHER QUESTION
ABOUT THE DATA IS. WHO'S BEING
PASSED OVER FOR PROMOTION AND
STAYING OUT OF A LOWER LEVEL
AND WHOSE ACTUALLY LEAVING I
THINK TED IS EXAMPLE OF LEAVING
TO GO START A COMPANY. SO IN
ADDITION TO BIAS IN HIRING
PROMOTION I'M JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT INCLUSION IS
REALLY CRITICAL. AND THEN WE
ALSO SEE THE GLASS CEILING FOR.
ASIAN WOMEN SPECIFICALLY
EXTENDING INTO ENTREPRENEURSHIP
AND VENTURE CAPITAL. AND THIS
IS AN AREA THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
TON OF DATA BUT ASIANS AS A
WHOLE COMPRISE JUST 12% OF ALL
START UP FOUNDERS EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE MUCH LARGER. PROPORTION
OF THE TECH WORK FORCE. AND WE
DID A SMALL STUDY OF ABOUT
FIFTY FEMALE TECH FOUNDERS AND
FOUND THAT. SORRY FIFTY FEMALE
TECH FOUNDERS AND FOUND THAT.
EAST SOUTHEAST AND SOUTH ASIAN
X. IT WOMEN EXPERIENCE
STEREOTYPES ABOUT RACE
UNWELCOME COMMENTS ABOUT
LANGUAGE COUNTRY OF ORIGIN.
ETCETERA DURING THE PROCESS OF
PITCHING THEIR COMPANIES IDEAS.
AND THAT BEN US A FAX
DISPARITIES IN IN CAPITAL THAT
COULD BE INVESTED IN THEIR
COMPANIES. AND THEN IN VENTURE
CAPITAL ASIAN MEN ARE THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE
INVESTORS THAN ASIAN WOMEN. SO
IN CONCLUSION I WE KNOW ASIAN
POPULATIONS ARE THE FASTEST
GROWING IN THE U. S. AND ALSO.
RECENT RESEARCH FROM THE PEW
RESEARCH CENTER SO THAT ANY
QUALITY WITHIN THE ASIAN
COMMUNITY IS GROWING MOST
RAPIDLY THAN ANY OTHER SUB
GROUP WHICH IS. A REALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE TO POINT OUT.
AND SO AS TECHNOLOGY CONTINUES
TO PLAY. AN INTEGRAL PART OF
OUR ECONOMY AND ESPECIALLY OUR
ECONOMY HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I
HAVE THREE QUICK
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE
PARTICIPATION AND SUCCESS. OF
API'S ONE IS REALLY
ARTICULATING THE NEED FOR US
AGGREGATED DATA COLLECTION. IN
C. AND REPORTING SO DE
SEGREGATION AT. THE STATE LEVEL
IN EDUCATION DATA AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL. I'M NATIONAL
SCIENCE FOUNDATION DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND THAT THE WORK
FORCE LEVEL WITH THE EEOC DATA
AND ALSO WITH THE COMPANY
DIVERSE REPORTS. AND THEN.
SPECIFIC THIS IS THE RESEARCH
ON. ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
POPULATIONS THAT ARE MOST
UNDERSERVED AND USING THAT
INFORMATION TO HELP DRIVE
INTERVENTIONS. AND THEN
SECONDLY COMPUTER SCIENCE
ACCESS AND EQUITY IN K. TWELVE
AND AGAIN FOCUSING SPECIFICALLY
ON WHAT WHO ARE THE POPULATIONS
THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY BEING
SERVED. WITH A FOCUS ON LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND GIRLS.
AND THEN FINALLY INCREASING
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
EXPERIENCES THAT ARE AT THE
INTERSECTION OF RACE AND GENDER
AFFECTING ASIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER WOMEN AND THEN
TARGETING INTERVENTIONS TOWARDS
A SOLUTION. SO WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY GIVE
SOME REMARKS. THANK YOU AND
FINALLY. I'LL JUST DO A QUICK
THANK YOU OKAY SAYING THEY WERE
RUNNING OUT OF TIME SO I AM THE
CEO OF WATER MARK AND WATER
MARK IS THE LARGEST WOMEN'S
ORGANIZATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA M. AS WAS MENTIONED
IN MY BIO WE FOCUS ON
DEVELOPMENT OF WOMEN AND WE
ALSO FOCUS ON THE INTERSECTION
ALLERGY ISSUES. WOMEN FACE. SO
I'D LIKE TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT AN EXAMPLE SO WE WERE
SORT OF BOOK ENDING WITH TED
AND I IN TERMS OF A OF A
PERSONAL EXAMPLE AND THIS IS IN
REFERENCE TO WHAT I SAW WHEN I
WAS CHIEF IN MY TIME AS CHIEF
DIVERSITY OFFICER AT CISCO. AND
I THINK THIS WILL REINFORCE
SOME OF THE REQUESTS THAT WERE
MADE. SO WHAT HAPPENED WHAT I
NOTICED DURING MY TENURE AS
CHIEF DIVERSITY OFFICER IS IT'S
PRETTY SIMPLE AND EASY TO
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES AND
CHALLENGES FOR BLACK AND LATINO
X. POPULATIONS IT'S A
RECRUITMENT ISSUE AND SO WHEN
YOU'RE WHEN YOU KNOW IT'S A
RECRUITMENT ISSUE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE MINISCULE POPULATIONS YOU
CAN RECRUIT AT ANY LEVEL WHICH
MEANS YOU CAN RECRUIT A V. P.
N. S. VP OR AN EXECUTIVE. THAT
HAS A HIGHER BANG FOR YOUR BUCK
THEN IF YOUR CREW A FIRST LEVEL
PERSON YOU KNOW AT. AN AN ENTRY
LEVEL ENGINEER. WHAT WE FOUND
WAS THAT THERE REALLY THE
PERCEPTION AS HAS BEEN SPOKEN
ABOUT WAS THAT THERE WAS AN
OVER SUBSCRIPTION OR CERTAINLY
ADEQUATE POPULATION IN AT THE
ASIAN PACIFIC POPULATION AND SO
I WAS APPROACHED BY BACH IN ONE
OF HIS COLLEAGUES AND DENISE
AND ACTUALLY A GROUP OF TWELVE.
ASIAN LEADERS AT AT CISCO WHO
SAID WE THINK THAT THIS HAS TO
BE RAISED TO OUR CEO JOHN
CHAMBERS AT THE TIME. SO WE
ARRANGED A MEETING WITH JOHN
AND WE THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO
BE A VERY QUICK MEETING JOHN
ALSO THOUGHT IT WAS GONNA BE A
VERY QUICK MEETING AND THOUGHT
WE'RE GONNA CELEBRATE HOW WELL
HE WAS DOING. BECAUSE HE HAD TO
SENIOR V. P.'S WHO WERE ASIAN
AND HE WAS IMMEDIATELY START
OFF WITH ALL YOU'RE GOING TO
CONGRATULATE ME ABOUT PAN
COLLAGEN SO IN WE'RE LIKE. TIME
OUT NO AND I THINK IT WAS BUT
IMMEDIATELY JUMPED IN AND INTO
THE FRAY AND SAID WAIT A MINUTE
JOHN WE'RE HERE TO TELL YOU
EXACTLY THE REAL STORY AND SO.
WHILE WE SHARED WITH HIM THE
ACTUAL DATA AROUND IT'S NOT A
REPRESENTATION ISSUE AND IN
FACT YOU'RE COUNTING ON THE
ASIAN POPULATION TO SHORE UP OR
NUMBERS OUR OUR AGGREGATE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE OF COLOR. OUR
ASIAN POPULATION DOES NOT MOVE
UP THROUGH THE RANKS AND SO THE
TWO YOU CALLED OUT TERRIFIC AND
THE TWELVE IN THE ROOM. NICE
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
REPRESENTATION AND I LOVED YOUR
PYRAMID. WE'RE ALL AT THE
BOTTOM PREDOMINANTLY AND WHEN
YOU GET TO THE TOP OF THAT
PYRAMID IT'S ABYSMALLY SMALL.
AND PROPORTIONATELY IN AND
THAT'S WHY THE ASCEND REPORT
THAT SHOWS THAT PROPORTION IT.
PRESENTATION IS SO POWERFUL SO
WHAT HAPPENED IN THAT MEETING
AND THIS IS WHY I THINK THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT STORY EVEN THOUGH
IT'S A BIT DATED WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE MEETING. IS WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A SHORT MEETING
JOHN IMMEDIATELY SAID WE NEED
MORE TIME. SO HE SAID THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I NEED
TO DIG INTO IT AND SO HE
LISTENED AND HE HEARD THE
ISSUES AND CHALLENGES THAT WERE
ACTUALLY BEING FACED BY HIS
LARGE HIS SECOND LARGEST
PERCENT. OF HIS EMPLOYEES WERE
FACING A CRITICAL ISSUE AND HE
HAD NO IDEA OF IT. ONCE HE
KNEW. AT W. EXTENDED MEETINGS
HE SAID OKAY WE HAVE TO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT AND WE HAVE TO DO
SOME THINGS. SO HE PUT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN TWO REALLY DENISE'S HEAVENS
AND A FEW OTHERS AND SAID. COME
TO US WITH COME BACK WITH
SALUTE I WANT YOU TO COME BACK
IN. ME AS CHIEF DIVERSITY
OFFICER THE LEADERS COME BACK
IN WITH SOLUTIONS AND PART OF
THOSE SOLUTIONS WERE LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT BUT PART OF THOSE
SOLUTIONS WERE A SPONSORSHIP
PROGRAM PART OF THE SOLUTIONS
WERE OTHER. ELEMENTS THAT WE
KNEW WE HAD TO. SHIFT IN THE
CULTURE AND SO ESSENTIALLY THIS
EXAMPLE. HAS BEEN PLAYED OUT
FOR ME AND IN MY CONSULTING
WORK THROUGH THE YEARS AND ALSO
WHAT I HEAR FROM THE SENIOR
EXECUTIVE LEADERS THAT
PARTICIPATED WATERMARK IF YOU
HAVE NO VISIBILITY TO A PROBLEM
AND I THINK. ON HE SAID THIS
INITIALLY USING A MEDICAL
METAPHOR IF YOU DON'T KNOW
THERE'S A MEDICAL ISSUE YOU
CAN'T FIND A CURE. DIVERSITY
PROBLEMS ARE HARD AND WE KNOW
BRING THAT IS NOT OF A QUICK
FIX AND IT'S NOT IN A PIT BUT
THERE'S NO MAGIC PILL BUT IF
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM YOU CAN'T BEGIN TO
ADDRESS IT. I WILL TELL YOU THE
EXPERIENCE THAT WAS VERY
DIFFERENT AND THAT'S ONE THAT
WE SAW WITH THE HR SEE WHICH IS
THE COMMUNITY THE RIGHTS
COMMISSION THAT THAT SHARE IS
WHAT COMPANIES ARE DOING WELL
IN TERMS OF SUPPORT. BILL G.
COMMUNITY AND WHAT COMPANIES
ARE NOT. THE TWO PRONGED
APPROACH NOT ONLY DOES THAT
VISIBILITY FORCE COMPANIES TO
SAY WE BETTER BE ON THAT LIST
BECAUSE WE WANNA TRACKED GOOD
TALENTED FOR NOT. BUT CONSUMERS
OF COMPANY PRODUCTS ALSO KNOW
WHO'S ON THE LIST AND WHO'S NOT
SO. IF YOU WANT ME TO GO SEE A
MOVIE AND I KNOW THAT'S A MOVIE
THAT SUPPORTED DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION I'M GONNA GO SEE IT
AND SO SHINING A LIGHT SHARING
THE EOC ONE DATA. IS NOT ONLY
GOING TO HELP COMPANIES. RISE
TO THE OCCASION WHEN THEY KNOW
THEIR DATE IS GOING TO BE
PUBLIC BUT IT HELPS THE- PUBLIC
AT LARGE SAY. I'M GONNA BUY
THAT PRODUCT YOU KNOW YOU'VE
GOT A CHOICE CAN YOU GO CAN YOU
SUPPORT JUNIPER OR CISCO OR THE
NEXT COMPANY ON THE BLOCK WILL
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE
COMPANY THAT SUPPORTS.
DIVERSITY AND MY POPULATION AND
SO I THINK IT'S CRITICAL FOR SO
MANY REASONS AND SO. I WOULD
SAY THAT IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT YOU CAN
DO TO SUPPORT ELEVATION AND
GREATER INCLUSION AND IT AND IT
ABSOLUTELY WORKS WE SAW THAT
THE- SHIFT IN AND I AGREE WITH
WITH LINDA WE NEED YOU MORE ON
BOARDS. BUT WE'VE SEEN A CHANGE
AND BOARDS WE HAVE NOT SEEN A
CHANGE IN CORPORATE LEADERSHIP.
AND SO THE MANDATE AND THE
VISIBILITY OF BOARD
REPRESENTATION HAS HELPED. WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT SAME GROWTH
IN LEADERSHIP AND COMPANIES AND
THIS WOULD HELP TO THAT AND
HELPED DRIVE IT SO I'LL I'LL
CLOSE WITH THAT AND SAY THANK
YOU AGAIN. FOR RAISING THIS TO
ALL OF US AND RAISING THE
VISIBILITY OKAY WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU EVERYONE QUESTIONS
ULTRASOUND OUT SEVERAL. JOHN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND I THINK WE'VE
HEARD OF QUITE A FEW. A GOOD
SUGGESTIONS. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
FOLLOW UP SO IF I MAY I LIKE TO
START WITH BUCK AND I THINK OF
ALL THE TECH COMPANIES THAT
HEALTH DECIDED TO. PUBLISH OR
DISCLOSE IT TO C. ONE REPORT I
HAVE WE SEEN IT AN IMPROVEMENT
WHATSOEVER IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER HIRING. AT THE HIGHER UP
LEVELS YOU KNOW. DO WE HAVE ANY
STATISTICS SHOWING THAT AT ALL.
SO A PRELIMINARY. TO CALL HIS
FIRST COMMENT IS THAT SO WE
TRACKED THEY ACTUALLY THE
REPORT. WE TRY EOC DATA FROM
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHAT YOU SEE WITH
REGARD TO ASIAN AMERICANS IS
THAT. OF THEY'RE NOW OF THE
NUMBERS TO MAKE AMERICA THAT
REPRESENTATION OR- IN THE WORKS
SAYS THREE SO THE WAY THAT AND
NOW THE LARA. MY LARGE RACIAL
GROUP WITH REGARD TO RELATIVE
REPRESENTATION IN MIDDLE
MANAGEMENT AND EXACTLY
MANAGEMENT THERE'S BEEN
VIRTUALLY NO CHANGE THEIR
NUMBER AGAIN THE NUMBERS HAVE
INCREASED BECAUSE THE JUST THE
NUMBERS OF WORKERS AGREES BUT
IN TERMS OF PERCENTAGE
REPRESENTATION OF THAT HASN'T
CHANGED SO SEVEN DID THIS AS
SPEAK TO THE EFFECTIVENESS OR
LACK THERE OFF OF US THE
DISCLOSURE ITSELF OR OR IT
DOESN'T DOESN'T DO THAT IN YOUR
VIEW. IS IT THE. NO EFFECT ON
LOOKS AT IT AND IT AND UNTIL WE
START LOOKING AT THE DATA SURE
NO ONE HAD AND I KNOW THIS
BECAUSE I TALK TO RESEARCHERS
THAT YOU'LL SEE I TALKED IT THE
RICHARD I KNEW YOU WERE SEEN
HAMPSHIRE AT THAT CLAIMANT NO
ONE IS ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE A
WHERE THE ISSUE NO THEY'VE BEEN
SO FOLKS AND OTHER ISSUES KNOWN
EXACTLY CRUNCH DATA THE DATA I
FOUND ERRORS IN EO ONE REPORTS
THAT NO ONE HAD CAUGHT BEFORE
AND I'M SENATE COMPANY AND SAYS
AND I'VE SAID. IS THIS RIGHT IS
IT NO THAT'S WRONG SO DATE IT'S
BEEN THERE BUT NORTH LOOK AT
AND NOW THERE'S A THERE'S A
COHORT OF RESEARCHERS INCLUDING
CAME CLAIM IT AND. AND FOR POOR
AND SEND. NOW THEY CAN DO
SOMETHING WITH IT. GOT A
QUESTION FOR LINDA I THINK YOU
MENTIONED THERE'S A TERM THAT I
DIDN'T QUITE UNDERSTAND IT'S A
RECYCLE RATE WITH RESPECT TO
THE BOARD TO MAKE UP. AND CAN
YOU EXPLAIN WHAT THAT IS AND
HOW THAT WORKS PLEASE YEAH SO
WHAT IT TAUGHT WHAT IT SPEAKS
TO IS THAT FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
WERE PLACED ON SCHOOL BOARD. OR
ACTUALLY MAYBE VERNON JORDAN'S
PROBABLY THE MOST FAMOUS
EXAMPLE VERNON JORDAN SAT ON
SOMETHING LIKE EIGHT OR NINE
DIFFERENT BOARDS AND SO FORTH.
EACH TIME HE- IS SITTING L.
OCCUPYING ABOARD C. WHAT THAT'S
CALLED IS HOW MANY TIMES HAS HE
BEEN QUOTE UNQUOTE RECYCLED
ONTO A DIFFERENT FULLER AFTER.
YEAH GOT IT OKAY. FOR DOCTOR
SCOTT. THE NUMBERS AGAINST
ASIAN WOMEN'S IS STAGGERING. AS
YOU MENTIONED. SO I'M JUST
WONDERING ARE WE DOING ENOUGH
TO RECRUIT THEM. YOU KNOW TO
ENTER THE ARCHITECT FEEL OUR
AND AT WHAT LEVEL WOULD WE- TWO
AT MOST EFFECTIVE WITH A LET'S
SAY YOU KNOW IT WHETHER IT'S
THE COLLEGE LEVEL OR EVEN A
LITTLE LOWER. YEAH I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND I
THINK. SO WE HAVE A PROJECT
BASED ON WOMEN OF COLOR IN
COMPUTING AND WE TALK ABOUT THE
ENTIRE PIPELINE AND I THINK K.
TWELVE IS OBVIOUSLY VERY
CRITICAL AND THEN YOU SEE KIND
OF A DROP OFF OVER TIME I'M FOR
ALL GROUPS I'M FOR ALL. GROUPS
OF WOMEN ARE WOMEN FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS I WOULD LOVE TO DIG
INTO MORE OF THE DATE OF THE C.
WHERE SPECIFICALLY THE DROP OFF
IS FOR ASIAN WOMEN BUT GIVEN
THE- GIVEN THE FACT THAT ONLY
70% ARE ONLY 30% OF THE ONES
TAKING A PCS ARE. ARE WOMEN I
WOULD I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
THERE'S A SOMETHING THAT WE
COULD BE DOING AND I PRE K.
TWELVE EDUCATION AS WELL AND
DON'T WANT TO I MEAN I THINK
THIS COVERS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SAY THAT THIS IS UP A PIPELINE
ISSUE IN THAT WE DON'T JUST
FOCUS THERE AND SAY IF WE JUST
FIX K. TWELVE THEN WE CAN FIX
ISSUES IN THE WORKPLACE OR IN
IN A- PROMOTION BUT ABSOLUTELY
I THINK IT'S WORTH. IT TO DO.
OKAY THANK X. JUST CLICK JUST
JUST IT JUST COVER SOME TURN.
CHECK THE C. SILICON VALLEY
FREES UP THE NUMBERS WE LOOKED
AT. TWENTY SIXTY. TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. 40% OF THE TECH
WORKERS WERE ASIAN WOMEN.
SENATE TECH WORKERS WERE WHITE
WOMEN. GOT IT GOT IT THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS YES IN TERMS OF
SO SOME YOUR SUGGESTION SEEMS
TO IMPLY THAT PERHAPS ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES AND THIS IS A
CHALLENGE FOR I THINK MANY
MINORITY GROUPS IS I GUESS A
LACK OF. WHAT COULD TERM SOCIAL
CAPITAL NETWORKING ABILITY AND
SO FORTH. AND THEN I REALIZED
THAT THAT THESE TWO THINGS MAY
ALSO INTERACT TO WHAT DEGREE IS
IT THE LACK YOU KNOW SO YOU
WERE AN ASIAN AND- WORKING
ATTACK STERN ALOT OF ASIANS AND
SENIOR MANAGEMENT SO YOU HAVE
VERY FEW PEOPLE WHO THINK OF
YOU TO PULL YOU UP. NOT THAT
THE PERSON HAS TO BE ASIAN TO
PULL YOU UP BUT YOU'RE LESS
LIKELY HAVE. YOU KNOW MAYBE
SOCIAL RELATIONSHIPS OTHER
THINGS. TO WHAT DEGREE IS IT
THAT THE SORT OF THE YOUR OF
CONNECTIONS ARE MAINLY WITH
PEOPLE IN YOUR OWN RANK AND NOT
THERE FOR PEOPLE ABOVE SO YOU
DON'T GET PULLED UP. VERSUS
STEREOTYPES LIKE ASIANS JUST
AREN'T YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOOD
ENGINEERS ARE JUST NOT GOOD
MANAGERS. AND THAT AND SO. SO
I'M JUST TRY IT TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THAT PARTICULAR
ATTENTION ABOUT STEREOTYPES
VERSES LIKE. HEY YOU KNOW WHAT.
YEAH JOHNNY IS A REALLY GOOD
PERSON AND BUT I'VE NEVER GOT
IT I DON'T REALLY THINK OF HIM
AS IT DID GOES BACK TO WHAT I
SEE PEOPLE AS- I DON'T SEE THAT
PERSON AS A C. L. OR AS A
SENIOR MANAGER BECAUSE- THEY'RE
REALLY GOOD ENGINEERING CODING
BUT THEY'RE NOT SO GOOD. YEAH
BUT I DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW. SO I
DID START. I THINK IT'S A
COMBINATION OF BOTH THINGS. AND
I HAVE DONE. INCLUSIVE
LEADERSHIP TRAINING. ACROSS THE
BOARD FROM THE FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED SO THAT START UPS. WHAT
I HEAR CONSISTENTLY IS A
COMBINATION OF BOTH THINGS ONE
IS. A LACK OF SPONSORSHIP FROM
SENIOR PEOPLE PULLING PEOPLE UP.
AND THERE ARE NOT PEOPLE LIKE
ME AND I THINK IT WAS SAID BY A
FEW PEOPLE YOU WANT TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT THAT SENIOR TEAM AND
SAY THEY'RE PEOPLE LIKE ME I'M
GONNA STICK IT OUT AND TOUGH IT
OUT AND FIND THOSE ADVOCATES
AND NETWORK IN MY OWN WAY. SO
THERE IS THAT IS A LACK AND
THAT IT THAT IS OF CONCERN THE
SECOND THING IT IS THAT THEY'RE
ABSOLUTELY ARE NOT JUST
UNCONSCIOUS BIASES BUT
CONSCIOUS VERY CONSCIOUS BIASES
THERE ARE. THERE CONTINUE TO BE
THE QUESTIONS OF WHERE YOU KNOW
WHERE YOU REALLY FROM I'M FROM
OHIO NO BUT WHERE YOU. FROM
REALLY FROM OHIO. THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS GREAT ON PEOPLE THEY
DEMORALIZED PEOPLE AND ALL OF
THOSE THINGS SO YOU'RE FACED
WITH I DON'T SEE ANYONE LIKE ME
IN SENIOR MANAGEMENT I DON'T
HAVE ANYONE ADVOCATING FOR ME
UNLESS THEY'RE ASSIGNED. IT'S
HARDER FOR ME TO NETWORK ALL
UP. AND THERE'S THE PERCEPTION
THAT I DON'T HAVE THE
LEADERSHIP SKILLS BECAUSE I'M
I'M ESPECIALLY IF I'M OUT ON
ASIAN WOMAN. I DON'T SPEAK UP
ON NOT ASSERTIVE IT CETERA
ETCETERA AND ALL OF THE OTHER
BIASES THAT COME ALONG SO
YOU'RE FIGHTING THE STEREO
TYPES THE BIASES. AND YOU DON'T
HAVE THOSE ROLE MODELS AT THE
SAME TIME SO IT'S A SORT OF A
ONE TWO PUNCH. IT IS A. ALSO
HAVE SOME ANSWERS THAT QUESTION
BUT I'M SCOTT IT'S UP TO THE
LOW ANDY CAN IF ANYONE TO
FOLLOWS UP DANCE YOU CAN
REFLECT. SO OFTEN THERE'S YOU
KNOW WHAT SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS ARE WE NEED TO HAVE
MORE LIKE LEADERSHIP TRAINING
AND SO FORTH AND I'M NOT SAYING
THAT THAT DOESN'T HAVE VALUE.
BUT TO WHAT DEGREE WOULD BE. IS
THE PROBLEM REALLY THAT THE
PERSON HAS A LACK OF LEADERSHIP
TRAINING AND SKILLS AND- AND
TODAY WE PREFER C. LIKE MAYBE I
GOT MORE LEADERSHIP TRAINING
I'LL BE ABLE TO MOVE UP VERSUS.
WELL IF THE PERSON WHO'S HIRING
THE BUT THAT LEVEL. YEAH WASN'T
SO DISCRIMINATORY ARE HAD
PRECONCEPTIONS ABOUT WHO I WAS
IS IT IS US IS THAT. THAT'S A
LEADERSHIP TRAINING IS
IMPORTANT BUT TO WHAT DEGREE
ARE PEOPLE SEEKING LEADERSHIP
TRAINING EMBEDDING IN
THEMSELVES. AT A SENSE THAT
THEY'RE MISSING SOMETHING THAT
IS IT REALLY A LACK IN
THEMSELVES BUT IS REALLY A LACK
IN THE PERSON WHO AND THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPPOSE THE
HIRING THEM LIKE. SO WE GOT ALL
THESE ARE TRAINING THEY WANT
BUT IT IS ALSO KNOWN PERCEIVE
THEM AS HAVING IT YEAH THEY'RE
NEVER GOING TO. PREVENT THEM SO
WHAT WELL I WOULD SAY IT'S TWO
FOLD IT'S THE IT'S- IT'S NOT
JUST DEVELOPING YOUR OWN
LEADERSHIP SKILLS I THINK IT'S
MORE OF AN ISSUE OF DEVELOPING
LEADERSHIP SKILLS OF LEADERS OR
SELECTING THE PEOPLE. ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'RE DOING AT
WATERMARK IS WE'RE WORKING WITH
SOME COMPANIES LIKE PIPELINE
EQUITY THAT SAY FOR EVERY
PROMOTION WE LOOK AT THE
SKILLS. AND FILTER OUT THE
RACIAL INFORMATION AND THE NAME
AND ALL THAT OTHER STUFF AND IF
YOU DON'T HIRE THE BEST
QUALIFIED PERSON YOU NEED TO
JUSTIFY WHAT WHY NOT. SO THAT
FILTER OUT THE IF THESE. AND
WE'RE HELPING COMPANIES THAT
WATERMARK PARTNER TO SAY YOU
NEED IS THE POOL. BECAUSE YOU.
WERE P. HUMANS AND NOT GOING TO
DODD BIASED. AT THE SAME TIME I
ALSO THINK YOU WANT TO. A.
WANTED THEIR OWN. SKILLS THAT
THAT'S A NO BRAINER BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT'S THE HOLD UP OKAY
WHAT I'D LIKE. JUMP IN ON THIS
CONVERSATION SO. I THINK THAT
THERE IT'S A IT'S A MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED AND NUANCED KIND OF
PERSPECTIVE I THINK IT'S
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID BUT I
THINK THAT FROM A LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT PERSPECTIVE I THINK
THERE'S- ET. SOMEONE CALL WROTE
IT YOU KNOW MENTIONED THE CODE
SWITCHING THAT MANY OF US WHO
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE TO DO.
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T JUST WALK IN
AND JUST ASSUME PEOPLE ARE JUST
GONNA ACCEPT US THE WAY WE ARE
IN AND WE'VE LEARNED TO DO THAT
BUT I THINK SOMETIMES. IT'S THE
DEGREE TO WHICH WE HAVE TO CODE
SWITCH AND SOMETIMES WE GET
STUCK IN THIS YOU KNOW HOW TO
WHITE. HONOR QUITE M. FROM A
CULTURAL PERSPECTIVE MIGHT
MIGHT MY IDENTITY AND MY VALUES
AND STILL BE ABLE TO NAVIGATE
THIS ORGANIZATION THAT EXPECTS
CERTAIN THINGS OF US. AND I
THINK BEING ABLE TO GO THROUGH
SOME OF THESE. I'LL CALL IT
CULTURALLY A RIPPLE OF IN
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE TYPE OF
LEADERSHIP BALL MINT IS IT NOT
THE LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT
ITSELF IT'S ABOUT HOW DO WE
GROW OR SOLD. AND SO THAT WE
CAN. THIS. HOW TO. OFTENTIMES
AT TAUGHT THINGS IN A CERTAIN
WAY RIGHT RESPECT ELDERS MEANS.
AND DON'T SAY ANYTHING IN A
MEETING BUT SOMETIMES RESPECT
RESPECT YOUR YOUR BOSS MEANS
YOU HAVE TO SPEAK UP AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
TEACHING. EATING CODES WHICH IN
A WAY THAT ENABLES YOU TO HONOR
WHO YOU ARE BUT ALSO STILL BE
ABLE TO BE EFFECTIVE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT YOU'RE IN AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. I WILL ALSO MAKE
ONE OTHER COMMENT I THINK ALSO
THERE'S A CHALLENGE FOR ASIAN
AMERICANS WHO ARE IN LEADERSHIP
WHO DO NOT. HELP OTHERS.
PULLING THEM UP BECAUSE IT'S SO
SELF CONSCIOUS AND SO AFRAID OF
GETTING ACCUSED OF FAVORING OH
MY GOD GOD FORBID THAT THEY
HAVE TO HELP ANOTHER ASIAN
PERSON. THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT
THEY WILL NOT HELP OTHERS AT
ALL BUT NOBODY LIKE PETTY
TALKED ABOUT NOBODY QUESTIONS
WHEN PEOPLE PULL UP. YOU KNOW
WHEN WHITE GUYS PULL UP JUNIOR
WHITE MEN. AND NOBODY EVER
QUESTIONS THAT AND THAT'S ALSO
AN ISSUE IN OUR COMMUNITY TO. I
WOULD ALSO OFFER THAT THIS IS
PART OF THE DISCUSSION THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE TO HAVE WITH THE
LARGER COMMUNITY. AND THIS IS
THE KIND OF DISCUSSION I WOULD
LIKE TO SUGGEST THAT WE HAVE AT
THE SUMMIT THAT IF WE CAN
ORGANIZE IT. BECAUSE I THINK IS
A MULTI PART CONVERSATION
HAVING ASIANS DEVELOP THEIR OWN
LEADERSHIP STYLES AND GROWING
THERE YOURS IS ONE THING BUT
WHEN THEY GO BACK OUTSIDE THAT
LEADERSHIP TRAINING INTO THE
REGULAR WORKFORCE ARE
CONFRONTED WITH ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PERCEPTIONS ABOUT WHO
THEY ARE. AND OUR OWN
PERCEPTIONS ABOUT WHO THEY ARE
AS WELL AND THAT THE MORE
GLOBAL SOCIETY SO I THINK THIS
IS A- TWO PART CONVERSATION I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE- PUBLIC
PRIVATE. PARTNERSHIP ON THIS TO
EXTEND ANDERSON. AND THE ISSUES
ARE NOT JUST LIMITED TO BEES I.
HIGHER EDUCATION. NON PROFITS
WE ALL HAVE THE SAME CHALLENGES
IT IS AN ACROSS THE BOARD
SECTOR ISSUE. ALL RIGHT WELL I
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR A
YEAR 2% AND REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE AND THAT YOUR
INSIGHTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. OKAY NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AND I THINK MR IS THERE
A LIST PEOPLE. SO WE HAVE A
BACK MIKE FIVE PEOPLE WISH TO
MAKES BRIEF REMARKS WILL ASK IF
YOU CAN TRY TO KEEP YOUR MARKS
TO A MINUTE. AND CERTAINLY FEEL
FREE TO SUBMIT ANY. COMMENTS AS
WELL TO THE COMMITTEE AS WELL
SO. SO WE CAN JUST FIRST
INTRODUCE YOURSELF YOUR NAME IF
YOU HAVE THAT HERE FOR AN
ORGANIZATION AND THEN. YOUR
REMARKS RELATE TO THIS HEARING
THANK YOU WELCOME. TEST TEST
THERE YEAH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT SELECT
COMMITTEE TO BE HERE TODAY AND
HOLD THE WHOLE THIS GREAT
MEETING. THIS IS MY FIRST TIME
COMING TO AN EVENT LIKE THIS
I'M VERY EXCITED. I'M MY NAME
IS DAVID CHANG I AM CHAIRMAN OF
MONEY JADE WEST. A WE'VE BEEN
AROUND FOR ABOUT THIRTY YEARS A
FOCUSED ON. IMMIGRANTS AND
ASIANS WITHIN THE SILICON
VALLEY. WE WERE FOUNDED ABOUT
THIRTY YEARS AGO TO HELP.
IMMIGRANTS UP GET RESOURCES
THAT WERE REALLY REALLY LACKING
WHEN THEY FIRST CAME TO THE US.
ON NOW FLASHED. THREE YEARS WE
HAVE A MULTIPLE PILLARS AND.
BUT I REALLY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT. COMMUTE I CONTINUES TO
RECRUIT AND ACTUALLY BE MANAGED
BY VOLUNTEERS. AND WE ARE VERY
VERY CLOSELY TIED WITH THE
ASCEND GROUP THERE'S A LOT OF
US AND LEADERSHIP HERE ACTUALLY
VOLUNTEERS AS MENTORS FOR. RAM
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THEM IN
THE TRANSPARENCY MOVE OF SOME
OF THE EEOC DATA AS WELL SO I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE VERY
MUCH FOR COMING HERE. AND ON
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC.
REALLY VALUE TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OKAY SAYING. NO
ONE ELSE AT MICROPHONE. IT JIM.
THERE YOU GO WELCOME THANK YOU.
HELLO DOCTOR PAN TOM I MET YOU
AT ONE OF THE CAUCUS MEETINGS
DOWN IN SOUTH BAY I THIS IS
AGAIN ALSO THE FIRST TIME MY
JOIN THE COMMITTEE HERE AND
THAT IS TO HEARING IT'S VERY
ENLIGHTENING I MY NAME IS IRENE
SAYING MY JOB IS AS A MATH
TEACHER BUT I MEANT REPRESENT
MENTAL HEALTH. ALLIANCE FOR
CONTENT. THESE. ACTUALLY THE-
NO WE HAVE IS VERY MUCH ALIGNED
WITH LEGAL ENTERTAINMENT AS
WELL AS JOURNALISM ALL EYES TED
BECAUSE OF. IN ALL THESE AREAS
IMMIGRANTS AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN TRADITIONALLY UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUPS HAVE A MORE
STRESS AND MORE PRESSURE AND
FOR MORE. IF THEY WANT TO MOVE
UP THE RANKS THEY TEND TO HAVE
MORE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES SO WE
HAS THE ORGANIZATION HAD BEEN
WORKING WITH NOT ME WHICH IS
NATIONAL ALLIANCE FOR MENTAL.
HEALTH. VERY CLOSELY FOR THE
LAST OF FOR FIVE YEARS RIGHT
NOW WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO. AT
B. B. I. CHAPTER FOR THE NINETY
CALL THEM THE CHINESE SO I'LL
TALK TO YOU AFTER THIS BUT WHAT
WE WANT TO DO IS TO BRING THE
RESOURCES FROM THE MENTAL
HEALTH COMMUNITY TWO PEOPLE WHO
SPEAK THEIR OWN LANGUAGE AND
HAVE THEIR OWN CULTURE. SIGMOD
TO DEAL WITH AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR HELP THANKS THANK YOU
THANK YOU WELCOME WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR I'M JOHN
SHOES VENIA VICE CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIA LAW PATHWAYS. AWARE
ESTABLISHED TO DIVERSIFY THE
LEGAL ACTION IN CALIFORNIA AND
IT IS ESSENTIAL I THINK WITH
THAT WHAT THE JUDGE TALKED
ABOUT. I ENDED UP ALL THE SALES
OF I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR. I
MEAN THIS. WE'LL HAVE ALL THESE
EXPERTS SPEAK ON A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT LEVEL.
FEELS I WOULD JOIN MY FRIEND
DENISE PACKS CALL FOR A
STATEWIDE SUMMIT OTHERS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ONE OTHER
STATES FOR EXAMPLE ILLINOIS
RECENTLY LOOKED AT EXPANDING
AND REQUIRING PEOPLE OF COLOR
ON CORPORATE BOARDS. STARTED
OUT WITH AFRICAN AMERICANS ONLY
THE END OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
SAID WELL WHERE WE WHY ARE WE
NOT INCLUDED FILIPINOS ARE
INCLUDED EVENTUALLY DURATION
OF. KAPIT INCLUDING ALL GROUPS
SO THERE'S A PARTNER TO INCLUDE
ALL GROUPS IN THE IN THIS
EFFORT FOR DIVERSITY
PARTICULARLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA LAW PATHWAYS AS A
PARTNERSHIP FROM SCHOOL
ACADEMIES TWENTY FOUR
COMMUNITY. IS TWO SOLDIERS OF
THE LAW. WE WANT OUR PART AT
FIRST BY THE PROFESSION. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER ANY ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY SO C. NINE
I WANTED TO FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF OUR SPEAKERS
WHO TESTIFIED BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IN OUR CAUCUS
TODAY I KNOW MANY ACTUALLY HAD
TO FLY IN AND HAD TO CATCH
PLANES FLYING OUT AND SO HAD
NOT EVERYBODY HAD TO LEAVE BUT
I THINK THIS IS BENDING STREAM
WE RICH DISCUSSION AND VERY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION. I ONLY
REGRET THAT WE UNFORTUNATELY
ONLY HAVE A FAIRLY LIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME AND EVEN IN THE
ESSENTIALLY ABOUT TWO AND A
HALF HOURS WE SPENT WE'VE ONLY
SAYS I THINK KIND OF SCRATCH
THE SURFACE IN MANY WAYS NOT
STOP BECAUSE OUR WONDERFUL
SPEAKERS HAVE BEEN IT. DON'T
BRING KNOWLEDGE IS JUST BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO
REALLY DELVE INTO BY THE IDEA
OF A SOLID WALL OF. FIGURE OUT
WOULD ORGANIZE A SUMMIT. BUT. I
REALLY GET. WHAT THEY CALL THE
SPEAKER. DODD THIS IS A WE
RAISE SOME REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUES HERE. AT CERTAINLY I
KNOW THAT THE SELECT COMMITTEE
AND THE API CAUCUS WILL BE
THINKING ABOUT THESE THINGS
THAT NOT THE CHAIR THE CAUCUS
BUT I'M SURE DAVID SHE WOULD.
AGREE AND- AT YOU'RE NODDING
YOUR HEAD SO THAT'S GOOD WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF US HERE SAY.
YEAH WE'RE THINKING ABOUT OKAY
WELL MAYBE SOME LEGISLATION
THAT WE MIGHT WANT TO THINK
ABOUT DOING BUT NOT JUST
LEGISLATION BECAUSE IS ALSO
LARGER. CULTURAL SYSTEMIC ISSUE
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS AND
THINKING ABOUT WHAT HOW HOW DO
WE TRY TO. BEN THAT NEEDLE AND
CHANGE. SO WITH THAT AGAIN I
WANNA THANK ALL OF YOU WHO.
RETIRED DIVISION TO COME HERE
AS WELL. AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE AND LISTENING.
TO IS HEARING AS WELL AND- WHAT
THAT WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA OF THIS HEARING AND THIS
US. HEARING OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ON API. FARES FOR THE STATE
TELL FOR STATE SENATE IS NOW
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.